representative
Brown will turn that who will turn that
a pink card when he gets a
chance I say again he couldn't hear you
who will turn in a pink card when he
gets the chance I will do that yes uh
thank you madam chair and good morning
uh fellow committee members it's nice to
be here in front of all of you so a
little bit of a story I'm going to tell
here which will actually carry over to
the the one I'm going to do at 11:00
that way I won't have to tell that story
then so going back to May of 2023 last
year I had a call from a constituent and
that constituent said I have a new
business and the state's business and
economic development website has not
updated my business in five years ago
and I'm getting calls from people saying
your website says this and I'm a new
owner and that's not accurate
so this constituent was trying to get a
hold of someone to fix that and he
couldn't and it had been on the on the
on the verge of maybe three weeks he'd
been waiting for someone to help him out
so he called me and I went over and
talked to him I said okay let me see
what I can do so the first thing I did
was I went to the
website for visit nh.gov and well I'll
talk about that at 11 o'clock and more
length I couldn't find a phone number
there and then um I finally figured out
it was business in Economic Development
and I went to the state's employee
directory and found the commissioner's
office number and called there that
would have been let me see let me get
this right that was Monday May 21st I
called left a message at the
Commissioner's Office on on the
voicemail by Friday that week the 26th I
had heard nothing back I called the
following Monday on the 31st and left
the message and I heard nothing back and
finally I called the following day on
Tuesday Tuesday and did get a human in
the commissioner's office to talk to me
and they eventually put me through to
someone who called me back problem
solved everything taken care of um and
that got me to thinking that that having
as you know been a state employee and
trying to have been a good public
servant that that was just way too slow
and there was something wrong with that
process so I thought maybe we could
solve this in in a way that was as I've
been told by a a state agent this week
that's a blunt object to use a law to do
this but that may be the case and that's
okay so that's kind of the backstory to
this
um in another meeting from the deputy
agitant General I on another bill I
heard that there was a problem with this
that he had heard from some other
agencies that this might bump into the
91a 5day
reporting allowance uh call back
allowance and the whereas this is only 3
days so then I said okay I'll I'll I
picked six different agencies to call
that I
thought probably received a lot of
telephone calls heal human services DMV
do a
Dees and I can't remember what the other
two were and spoke to the Commissioner's
Office Andor whoever they gave me to as
a representative so I had a lot of
um a lot of feedback health and humorous
Services said we probably get 3,000
calls a week because we have so many
programs and and if you were to pass
this we probably would have to hire
someone to track every one of those
calls to make sure I got called back in
three days seems like a legitimate
statement to me and um I had some
similar statements from other agencies
uh I had one agency say well we're we're
not bad with the three days but how
would we ever do this with a voicemail
and track that we'd have to have a
person tracking every voicemail in the
agency so the the short story kind of
that is agencies were a little bit
hesitant on it and I I I understood
where they were coming from and I think
it was
fair um what a number of the agents did
say agencies did say was maybe an
interim
study maybe back up a little bit all of
them said every single one of them said
this is probably a good idea
philosophically and we should be
concentrating on customer service as the
governor's office wants us to and it's
not a bad idea aidea to look at this in
some way and see if it's a problem and
the suggestion was that uh from a number
of them was to go to interim
study
um make sure I covered everything I
wanted
to I also
heard interestingly enough as a side
issue on this from a couple of
Representatives and from uh from a
representative in the governor's office
that it's not it's it's kind of
related there were those that wanted me
to add into here that there should be a
way to force agencies to call state
representatives back more quickly but
obviously I didn't want to clutter this
up with that but just for future
reference for all of you to consider
that there was uh there's some concern
about that I've never had that problem
actually so anyway that's that's where
I'm at that's what I've got and I think
that the smartest thing might be to
interim study this this as we could
actually take a look
at what are the complaints coming in is
there a problem or is it just that I
happen to have a an individual issue
that seemed to be a problem and I I will
add to that that I have spoken to a
number of representatives and some of
them have said yes we we've uh found
similar problems uh one of the lawyers
in in town where I live said he had he's
had tough times with HHS and the court
system calls back so I don't think it's
a an isolated incident um and I think
it's from a public service standpoint uh
it's probably worth following up on any
at nope representative goalie you have a
question oh okay well I believe
representative Brown you've explained it
so well that we don't have any questions
so thank you
Williams
chairman McGuire and members of the um
executive department administration
committee uh for the record my name is
John Williams I'm the legislative
director for Health and Human Services
and represent Brown explained it so well
that I have no further commentary to
provide but otherwise supporting an
interm study for this Bill thank you are
questions Pres Smith can always count on
you to
contribute well my only question would
be that this describes the way things
obviously should
happen and and uh it's not like the
people in the in the offices or bureaus
or whatever so-called bureaucrats are
sitting around trying to figure out ways
to avoid doing what the public has
requested them to do um but if you got
the proverbial 10 pounds of stuff in a
five pound bag situation you got to get
another bag and or you got to take care
of what's backed up in front of you
so this is the this describes the ideal
world and this is not the world we live
Fitzpatrick uh thank you madam chair uh
I understand that the uh job of the
general court is
oversight but is
uh creating a mandate on how a member of
the executive branch uh performs their
duties is that an over an an overreach
for a legislative body you know se you
know separation of
powers um so chairman McGuire I do
appreciate the question and I do believe
that there is a clear distinction in
terms of separations of powers but also
uh in terms of constitutional analysis
there's a meaningful collaboration
between the various um uh branches of
government that the Judiciary talks with
the legislature the legislature talks
with the executive branch and it you
know pretty much both of them and all
three of them communicate with each
other well uh I do think that in this
particular um matter uh that it's an
important issue I know working with the
legislators serving on this committee
that they certainly adhere to The
Standard of returning calls within three
days and for the few who I've had the
pleasure of working with they also know
I reciprocate and also I want to just
point out that representative Brown uh
per his tenure at the uh Department of
Environmental Services was noted for his
Civility and his receptiveness to
getting back to the public on questions
and certainly the department would
adhere that that goal is an important
goal however the legislation is
currently drafted would present some
issues and but support an interim
study thank you madam chair thank you
others thank you seeing none thank you
very much does anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill
1420 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing okay executive session
representative grer you have a a motion
yes I'll move inm study on House Bill
1420 and I'll second it
okay yes I
she I have one but I'm leaving this for
the day when she forgets to give us one
there's some in my middle left drawer
too okay great all right we have a
motion of interim study by
representative grer do you wish to speak
to your motion yes um occasionally I do
hear from constituents who have
difficulty in re reaching state
agencies
and I call in their stad and I'm always
my calls are
always um responded to and I don't
believe that it's because State
agencies don't want to speak to
constituents it's just that they they
realize that we may be calling for a
specific thing so I do believe I do
think that interim study is
appropriate because I'm torn between
whether or not this should be coming
from the governor's office to their
state agencies as opposed to us to the
state agencies I do think that if the
governor um thinks that customer service
is important then he should Institute a
program
that um that that's designed for that so
let's take a look at it and see if we
can make recommendations and thank you
for bringing the bill to us represent
lus thank you y i uh you know I think we
certainly have the authority and I think
the duty to do something like this I
understand there's details to work out
but I hope that what comes out of inter
study is a recommendation for something
specific and maybe what happens if it
isn't met um but to deal with you know
whatever flexibility there might need to
be in certain
circumstances okay does anyone else have
a
comment represent BR you can join us
you're uh the testimony is over so
you're you're free to uh act as a member
of the
committee yes
sh it thank you sorry I was moving the
mic um I do agree that um that seems to
be the case I've had constituents
contact me uh who've waited days or
weeks for an answer and when I call
usually within a day or two I get an
answer for them which doesn't seem right
but I suppose that is part of the role
that we play um I do agree with
representative groda that um this
basically involves the executive
department so the top executive should
be the one uh mandating this uh I will
also point out that part of the problem
could be that a lot of our departments
don't have enough help to handle all the
calls and inquiries that they get so
that's my main comment thank you
represent Blas yeah I agree that you
know at least for some the problem might
be staff and you know if there if we
were to give them a mandate something
like this whether it's this one or or
adjusted then uh you know it'd be their
job to ask for what they needed to
actually do it and well I don't like
spending money you know do giving good
customer service I think is something we
have a duty to do yeah I'd like to
represent billan thank you madam chair I
wonder if this is more of more of just
an awareness issue I know um I've had an
personally had an issue Department of
Safety and I made a phone call and that
same day I had four phone calls back to
me from different members of the agency
to try to resolve the issue same thing
with constituent Services constituent
has an issue always get an immediate
response so I I wonder if it's just an
awareness in the agencies to be more uh
responsive and proactive uh and I I I
wonder if it really if it really needs
an interim study or just
uh a blast back to the to maybe through
the governor's office that to to be to
be aware of the fact that some
constituents are having an issue well I
I think that this relates very much to
representative Brown's other bill
because I would guess a lot of the
problem is people call the first person
they think of and that person is not the
right person to answer the question and
so they say gee I don't know the answer
to that do I know anybody who might and
sometimes they do and sometimes they
don't and if they don't they're likely
to say well I'll look into it when I
have the time and therefore it takes a
long time to get to it so I I think that
the fact that the programs and the
contact points for the programs are not
always readily available to our
constituents is a big part of the
problem we call the commissioner and say
hey who's who's the point person on such
and such an issue and the commissioner
finds that person for us it's not the
same for somebody that's calling a
random person in HHS with a question
representative ly thank you madam chair
sorry for coming in late um but my
concern I mean a point that I want to
make with this regarding to this is even
within the agency within the office the
shift of personnel I'll give you an
example for I asked for a proclamation
from this uh governor 's office and I
had sent all the information to the
individual that was doing that and 3
weeks later didn't hear nothing so I
went back to the governor's office and
asked what happened oh that person moved
from that position this is the new
person I said so I need to know who the
new person is didn't hear
anything so that could happen within any
agency the moving of
yes okay anyone else have a comment
question all right in that case the the
motion is interim study on House Bill
1420 and the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakus yes representative
Bailey yes representative Dolan
no clerk vote Yes representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair yes 15 y1
n okay the motion passes 15 to one is
consent I'm sorry no no objection in
that case we'll put it on consent and
representative Grotto of course at your
earliest
convenience all
right come out of executive session and
hearing
going to the first one's going along
with it probably won't do
anything because we were losing interest
day I don't see any
issue
twin no no there's a Senate bill that
updates the fire code right and there's
one
about um Municipal Amendment to the
building code which is which was
pointable Stu in the in the garage yeah
you know there's the there's the oil
snowblower
yes thank you well thank you I thought
ask
thank you chair and committee um my name
is uh representative Kelly Penza
straford District 19 um this bill came
to
fruition uh
from a a meeting um that took place
between um a group of constituents as
well as legislators
um at the at the Department of
Environmental Services um that's where
the idea of this bill came in and then
just in talking to um fellow um fellow
constituents as well as
legislators it seems as if um people
spend a lot of time in regards with
public comment and in that public
comment it just kind of seems like it's
out in a in a um in a black hole in a
sense
so this bill in a sense takes the public
comment puts it in a in a fashion that
it's online and um and then makes makes
it so especially on the with all the
agencies makes it so that there's like a
response um and some of these things are
are huge huge items for the state and so
um not knowing uh Specialists come in
scientists come in uh you know water
specialists in regards with the dees
conversation for example that took place
so I that's where that's where this bill
originated from so uh we have the
Technologies very easy to do um if
someone is giving a written Tech written
testimony it can just be scanned and put
online um but it's that's really how
this whole uh Bill originated and um
it's it's a it's got bipartisan support
this is uh just I think a way that we
should be having um some nice
transparency especially when people are
um spending the time uh sometimes people
travel hours on end to come and and
speak um at hearings at these agencies
and you know with Ru making and so
that's kind of where this whole bill
originated from if you have any
questions
thank you for your testimony are you
aware that last year we amended the
procedure act to require the agency to
report and reply to comments received at
the at the public hearing and I'm trying
to find out where exactly the citation
is but we did make a change to require a
response to
comments not quite as detailed as your
your bill but it's there and I'm trying
to find
it I think the difference is there's
something that's um versus response
versus um an
explanation I mean I can tell you that
there are there are entities that spend
a lot of money to be able to look things
over um because average people they're
not necessarily they're not scientists
and they don't and they don't know and
they can't they they take some sometimes
uh what an agency says as you know that
that's it and and that's the problem if
if we don't have if someone can say
that's not true and can refute that in
public testimony and then there's just a
response saying okay well we you know
thanks for your comment great but don't
give an actual reason why something
that's valid especially when I'm talking
about something that's scientific um why
they're not going to take that into
consideration is to me is just
negligent so I think that that agencies
are paid a lot of money and and uh in
regards and positions are and I think
that uh the public in a sense um needs
to be able to have a true explanation
why they wouldn't take into account um
really
thoughtful sometimes scientific expert
testimony that comes
in thank you representative Dolan thank
you madam chair uh in your in the bill
when uh the agency is required to
respond to public comment is is there
any requirement to have the the
response by the agency qualified or
reviewed for Content what if the
agency's response is argumentative or
not complete or uh not responsive to the
constituent how how how is that
captur it or follow it up
with well I guess you know in a sense
that the you know the public could bring
that to their representative uh so
someone like me that's the that's part
of the reason why this bill um is in
place because
some amazing testimony has just fallen
on deaf ear and this is not just in you
know that has to do with uh my committee
you know in the agencies that we work
with this has been going on for a long
time I I don't know in a sense how we
could police that I think putting this
bill in is holding um agencies
accountable and I think it's a step in
the right direction and and also telling
folks that are
um that are that are testifying and all
of that kind of stuff that they have
this now to say okay um can you can you
here's the law can you give me a better
response this it's saying that you you
have to give me a full explanation about
why you know why this expert testimony
considered any other questions
representative Simon thank you madam
chair uh I guess following up on
representative Dolan's question um the
only thing that I noticed in the bill
which I I have some experience with this
deal deal with landfill setting
requirements in main where they do it
and it's very helpful I mean in my
opinion uh my experience with it is very
helpful um the word significant in line
11 I'm just questioning whether or not
that's the right word there um what
signifies significant I don't know if a
word like pertinence might be more
applicable
uh what do you have any thoughts on that
no that's a great question and a great
point right because that that is um what
qualifies that statement I'd be willing
to to you know I could make a word
change there not a problem
um pertinent would probably be a better
choice
[Music]
um okay that's that's fine I just wasn't
sure if you had any particular no I
just fair enough you when someone
responds with public combat right you
know I oppose this bill I you know it
doesn't fit into my you know doesn't fit
into my agenda or whatever but versus
someone saying I oppose this bill
because it affects my life and this D D
D D D D you know what I mean so
something that's significant meaning
like that's not just a you know I oppose
this bill in in a oneline sentence so
significant was substantial but but I
think maybe pertinent or something could
be better choice or even removing that
um even removing significant allog
together and just having it be
argument followup um yeah I want to be
careful that I'm actually asking a
question um but so you're you're okay
with a word change there yeah I'd be
hesitant to take the word out altogether
because then it becomes somebody wants
to change the font on it and you know
then the department has to respond and
you don't want to get frivolous so I
understand the the need for the word
there um so that's fine um other just
real quick comment if I might I would
assume that the somebody go to the
courts as well if they felt like I mean
there's obviously no civil or criminal
penalty involved but they could sue to
get the Department to make a response
would be my
assumption they can also Sue to overturn
the rule if they like right representa
Brown uh thank you madam chair and
thanks for taking my question I I think
maybe following up by representative
Dolan a little bit so if if you have
have the wonderful experience of reading
the Federal Register and the development
of rules in the CFR
when there's a rule that's coming out
they have a generally a fairly lengthy
piece at the beginning of that that
explains how many people had comments
and then they address every
comment in the beginning of the the
Federal Register but what happens is
they basically address those comments
and say here's our decision end of story
is is that kind of so this is just going
to be we heard your argument here's our
answer to you and then moving forward is
guess I'm familiar uh a person that
helped me craft this is very familiar
with the federal process so
um the federal process is ex is they do
a good job right in regards with listing
all of that and but the piece that's
different here is it's not um this is
before the decision we want these things
to be disc we don't want this to come of
course after the decision so um
there there would have to there has to
be a reason so let's say if it it has to
do with
um let's say it has to do with landfill
sighting
if if specifically there's 10 items that
are on there that are you know 10 issues
with
um with with the rules that are being
proposed and none of those issues have
really had an argument that's come back
that it from the agency that has said
okay well you know we're able to prove
that you know this is not a problem this
is not a problem this is not a
problem then we're hoping that this is
going to make them reconsider before
they just blanketly say oh no we've just
decided so that's the point I I
understand where you're coming from the
FED they they do they very transparent I
love how um I actually looked at where
the comments are uh you know for all to
see which is wonderful that's what we're
looking for here as well um but this is
kind of like we would really like them
to be a little bit more intentional so
when we had this meeting for example
with Dees it was it was clear there was
a lot of stakeholders around the table
and um it was a really good conversation
but that's why this came out and to be
honest one of the gentlemen that deals
with all of the public you know kind of
the public comment piece in his division
um and I think he was in in air
resources um was he thought that this
was great so you know I don't know this
isn't specific to any one agency so I'm
not sure if there's going to be people
behind me that are going to say they
don't want this I don't I don't know
but so um but uh I I think that this
this is great because it should in a
sense help keep people feeling like
their voices are heard I mean right the
I work for the people and um and that's
the whole point of this and I just want
to make as
transparence transparency but also the
amount of amazing citizen experts that
we have is huge and I want people to be
able to see that kind of testimony
online and that's the kind of stuff that
you can see on the federal side that no
one even knows about you wouldn't I have
that's such a well um a wealth of
resource for so many people so thank you
other
questions okay are you aware of RSA 541
A2 Roman
2E which in case you don't have it
memorized I do not probably not says
that when they're issuing the final rule
which that will then come before Jael
car is that they must include a report
of public comments received and an
explanation of how they were addressed
that I don't believe it's redundant I
think this is prior to and if it could
um that could also
[Music]
um that could also alleviate maybe that
piece too so if it's happening um if
they've already done it like the this
way then they probably would just maybe
have to do a copy paste it wouldn't have
to do a second set of work if I'm making
myself clear yes okay what was that
reference 541 a colon 12 Roman 2 little
e thank you i' got to find
that okay but that all right thank you
yes represent G on that reference in
that that you're reading does it say who
the report needs to go to it is issu it
is part of the final package of of the
package of the final rule which is being
brought to before Jael car for approval
so Jael car is the only one that
receives the report it's a public
document it's posted on the website
prior to the jel car meeting okay thank
you not the easiest to find but it is
there I was just going to say that's
before I um before I became a legislator
I was kind of an activist if that's what
you want to call me um so and I didn't
understand and most people don't um they
don't I mean it's really even hard for
people to understand like they get the
basics how a bill becomes a law but just
even from committee and then
understanding the voting in the
committee and then going to the house
and and then to have to realize that
there's also this other piece with JL
car um I would have to say 90 99% of
people in New Hampshire um that are not
in politics have no idea about that
piece at all so you would I would not be
correct okay anyone else representative
Shu thank you madam chair um having
served on jel car myself
uh I'm well aware of the complaints that
we hear constantly how long it takes to
get things through
rules um and seeing in um section two
paragraph Roman numeral 3 uh provided
that the rule shall not be effective or
its adob adoption shall be postponed
until 90 days after the agency
explanation required is posted on the
agency's website so would you not say
that that is further prolonging the
whole
process
um I guess it could be I wasn't looking
at it that way
[Music]
um I was I was looking at from the time
that you know the rul making piece kind
of begins to um with public comment and
and I actually use that
90day based upon that conversation with
that person from Dees but I would be
happy to look at that if it was going to
um we don't I don't want anything to be
rushed because I want people to be have
to have enough time of course but I also
don't want to hold things up either so
um some of these rules that we have as
you know are in effect for some that
have they don't get changed they're in
effect for over a decade and so I I
think we have to be pretty smart I don't
mind being slow and steady but and and
not rush things but I'll look at that
specifically if that
um thank you like I said we do hear that
and and we know the process can be
lengthy and uh this looks like it would
be in addition to the lengthy process it
already exists yes other uh
questions represent Simon actually
question for the chair just for
clarification um because there are
people in the committee who have more
experience in this than I do um the 90
days how long does it usually take a
rule how how long is that process to get
to its completion and would the 90 days
be an addition to or would it be just
kind of lost in the shuffle of how long
it typically takes space there are
specific time rules for for everything
in the rul making process most of them
like after considering the comment the
agency establishes the final text of the
rule and then file it no earlier than 21
days and no later than 180 days so that
if the process is they develop their
final rule write these explanations
then this this would be additive okay
because this might be more appropriate
for EXA session but into that if they
have to ride that to jel car and then
jel car has to act there's actually more
time before the rule it's her thing is
when the rule goes into effect which is
not going to be till after jail Car Act
Right it seems like a lot of it maybe
all of it would be in parallel but it
would depend but I think the agency work
this would be in serious with their
rule so yeah except that they have to
present pretty much this information at
J car anyway don't they uh not in this
not as detail or something right but
anyway yes we'd have to look at it in
Greater
detail I love that you guys are talking
and I just wanted to say that it was um
there was a comment this was not made to
prolong this was made to be in parallel
with the process so if this doesn't jive
then um
then I'd be happy to make that change or
make it clear the one piece excuse me
you don't make the changes at this point
oh that's true you guys make the changes
that's true that's right just to save
you the bother of trying to do
it um the the other piece that has to do
with that is I'm looking at so from
where the rules making process
started um in my committee that we're
what we're dealing with I mean they were
we were talking about this in the summer
um there were you know the official I
don't know the official process started
like in October and here we are uh in
February and then we've got another
meeting in March I mean we're that it's
a real it was a it's a real long process
so I know we're talking about a you
know major rules that we're that we're
dealing in regards with permitting um um
per
landfill sighting but I don't know I I I
thought that it made sense in the scheme
of things but if it doesn't because this
needs to apply to all then you know
please make changes or let me know if I
need to look into something okay thank
you I just thank you madam chair I just
had a question is this going to
committee I think it it uh needs to sh
Ron deck for this
one obviously
okay and one thing we'll want to do is
is take a closer look at the Timeline to
make sure it's uh
not
additive and any other questions from
the committee seeing none thank you for
your
testimony is there anyone else who
1521 seeing none I will close the public
hearing
Jackie do you have the amendment for uh
this
you
no no represent uh opening the hearing
for House Bill
16006 and call Representative
Brown uh thank you again Madam chair and
committee
members you um so a follow up as I said
from the previous bill so I'm not going
to tell you the background story you all
heard that in you should have in front
of you this which is a pictures of web
pages and a little spreadsheet and an
amendment um I'm going to start off if
you if you go to this the pictures of
the web pages I'm going to go backwards
here actually if you go to the second
page the third page
technically it didn't come out very good
in copying there's three there's three
pictures here this is the visit nh.gov
website that the constituent tried to go
find the telephone number on um the top
picture is the when you first open the
web page up the very top picture the top
third of the page it doesn't come it
didn't come out very well uh there's no
phone number it's a it's a nice picture
and it says about uh Discovery in New
Hampshire places that say ET
T if you scroll down and go to the very
bottom of the page you can see where I
made the arrow on the left and that
there's a little tiny contact dust
button way down at the bottom of the
page when you open that at the very
bottom of the page the only thing you
get is that form that you fill out with
your name and email address you don't
get a telephone number you just that's
all you get so this is what kind of
prompted me to say this doesn't seem
very uh user friendly you can't even
find a phone number on there which is
what the constituent has
said um so I I took a look and if you go
back to the first page we can go through
a couple of
these um Department of Justice on front
page
there's an arrow on the top right you
can see they have contact by division
it's actually when you open it up it's
very very thorough and it's really good
uh the next one down a number of
websites have this type of an idea where
the contact us button I have an arrow
down there is way down in the bottom
left which it's it's obviously not uh
prioritized in that list be beyond all
the other things and page two kind of
gives you the same
idea uh State Police there so on page
two you see the arrow their contact us
button you have to go to about us first
before you get to the contact us button
and the fuel assistance program weirdly
enough their contact us button is again
at the bottom of the page like others so
I thought this all seems very
inconsistent
and I said okay well I'll let me take a
look at every single agency's website
well I I abandoned that
idea
Well I this you don't have to look at
this spreadsheet closely but this is as
far as I got before I talked to
doit um so I just took a look and said
what's visible on the main page so my
idea is at least if you open the website
up when you first open it up you
shouldn't have to go hunting anywhere
for a phone number so all of the ones
that have an X in this very first column
did have that and the ones that didn't
did not have that and then I kep track
of what they had inside the button which
is not really it's it's too much
information for you but that's just how
I I approached it um
so uh I I decided to make the same calls
I made for the phone call to different
agencies to see what their take was on
this and um I eventually ended up uh a
couple days ago talking to the
commissioner of doit Department of
Information
Technology he told me
that the uh the standard they're working
on they have been given a standard web
page designed by the governor's office
and they're working through getting all
of the web pages to match that standard
web page design he said they're about
73% of the way through if I or 75%
somewhere in there um it's a it's a slow
process of changing that um he said that
that standard web page the only
requirement for wear contact information
is is at the bottom of the web page as
you saw in a couple of
those um so that's kind of where that's
coming out of the governor's office he
also said if if I'm not misquoting what
he said that the governor is directly
responsible for changes to the standard
web page design and whenever that comes
up he talks to the governor directly for
that so that's kind of the background of
where all this is at uh I have an you
have an amendment in front of
you that
um addressed a couple of the concerns
agencies and if I can find my own copy
second too many papers as usual okay so
I I can quick run through the
amendment one of the big pieces was I
deleted um B and E I think from the
original in line in part three hang on I
got to find the original here we go on
the original
bill I'll take it from the top so it's
this says some
consistency um I added a definition in
for button because I kept using that
word button and I wanted to make sure it
was clear what that meant um doit hasn't
looked at that yet they might have a a a
better definition for what that means so
that as I use that word throughout it
made some sense
um and I added on line 10 I added a
standalone item at the top of the web
page as it so that it wasn't within
another menu or within another
button
uh and I put to direct the user to the
agency's contact information to be a
little more clear and this button sh
label contact contact us and after
talking to doit or other similar wording
which would readily indicate its purpose
so as Department of Justice says contact
by division I'm not 100% sure that I
would think that's I would agree with
that but it's I think it's
fine uh in in part
amendment which is part two in the
original bill I Chang contact or contact
us just to button so we we could we
didn't make them Define what it was
called and and then I put also in there
on line
15 to State the uniform design color and
size based upon the most recent webpage
design standards followed by doit that
means that this won't handcuff them if
the governor says I'd like to see it
done a little bit
differently
10 is now 3A on the
amendment and I just wanted to draw your
attention to this and I don't know no
nobody caught it nobody nobody commented
to me about it messages on this
telephone line from the public will will
be
monitored I had daily and I change that
to each state of New Hampshire business
day to ensure a prompt
response and then on the original Bill
line 13 uh doit caught and and this
could have been an OS translation of
what I originally wrote it said a direct
email link to the individual from the
public directly to the appropriate
employee within the agency division or
Bureau that actually would make no sense
to have a direct link to each
employee on the on the contact us button
so I I deleted that
in uh
line line 13 deleted
that I left in um I didn't get any push
back on this I thought I might what's
line what's now line 22 formerly line uh
15 a direct link to the Govern the sorry
line 21 a direct link to the state of
New Hampshire employee telephone
directory if you don't know that exists
that's amazing you should you should
check that out uh gives you every state
employees phone number
basically uh
line and line 15 and 16 on the original
stay the same I believe line 17 in the
deleted at the suggestion of the
commissioner doit it said a direct link
to all websites that exist for the
Department well that's that could be a
huge list obviously so and and they
every agency has other ways to go there
within their website
[Music]
um and then the the commissioner of doit
said 60 days if you want me to do this
money he said within 36 I'm I wasn't
trying to be funny I'm sorry within 365
days it would make sense that they could
accomplish that maybe without funding
but if we want to make it go quicker we
would have to to uh to fund some some uh
someone to do that and I think that's
very fair so that's where I am in the
amendment and that's the idea of where
I'm going and so the basic idea is
following up on this morning if someone
wants to call the state you know
thinking about maybe some of our older
citizens aren't as good with the
computer um you should be able to go to
the when you open the website contact us
there's a phone number or or or as fact
number or email that you can easily find
questions represent Dolan thank you
madam chair uh thank you representative
uh excellent work on this
uh question so as our technology screams
forward at the speed of light I'm
thinking that um very soon we're going
to be in a voice activated world uh
everything appears that almost
everything you you've captured here is
push a
button is has any thought or input being
thought to be given to the
state as they move forward to think
about voice activated uh access to to
the websites um that's a great point and
I hadn't had that conversation with
anyone and I'm sure that uh doit would
have some input on that and it could
be uh I could certainly talk them we
could
you could reward that as you thought it
was as you thought it was fitting um but
I think that's a good
point um I I I will follow up myself I
think um the commissioner at doit said
that he would have no problem with just
adding a a button to the top of web
pages without using this blunt
instrument of a law as as he thought and
and I I think that's also Fair um uh
the commissioner is here can and he will
speak for
himself hi hello have I said anything
you didn't say oh boy okay good well you
can you can speak to that yourself um so
and I I think we also had the
conversation that uh as as this comes
from the governor's office I I did not
go to the governor's office and have
that conversation with them so that
might be a step to take as well okay
thank you very much and seeing no other
questions
commissioner
goule
yes uh good morning uh Madame chair
members of the committee um my name is
Dennis goule I am the commissioner of
the Department of Information
Technology um I came here today to
testify in favor of of this bill um you
know I I I really want to thank the
sponsor for for calling me and and
talking through uh because we you know
that Amendment does address any concerns
that we have with the bill and you know
I think his point his main point that he
made to me which I thought was a good
one is our standard template that um
that we're rolling out to all the
agencies and he was pretty close to
correct were about 72% through um had to
contact us in the bottom
part which is kind of standard but his
point was you know that's not very
friendly you know up top right is better
and you know I I would agree and some of
the agencies have chosen to put uh their
contact us in the top right so I'm I'm
perfectly fine with doing that and um
and we'll we'll get on that I I think
it's appropriate that we do it as we
move we're moving we have a a really
nice new format that we use and and that
the all a we intend that all agencies
will be on we'll make it standard that
the contact us be in the top right
should um regardless whether this passes
or not and um and I think that's just
good it's good uh practice to make it
easier to get a hold of us we're happy
to place the a link to the employee
directory in there um and again the the
the line that was struck around you know
the you know kind of org chart of the of
the department in the contact us it
would make it kind of messy and hard to
absorb and it's it's different from what
we're trying to do which is to represent
our websites in terms of what what a
person going there might want to do
versus the or chart of the state so kind
of taking that you know abstracting it
out to what somebody might want to
accomplish by virtue of going to the
site and rather than oh here's a
department list so that was so I do
appreciate the sponsors flexibility on
that and uh that's it for my tech uh my
test happy to answer any questions
represent man
py thank you madam chair thank you uh
commissioner for taking my question uh
how often do you update
upgrade uh websites or
information digital information
available to
public um great question um so one of
the things we do is I have a a a staff
of about three people that are
responsible for over 100 um executive
branch website properties so uh the vast
majority of all content updates happen
at the agency level and it really varies
by agency but you know on the larger
agencies the content continually
changing um and and in fact uh HHS has
tens of people that are trained to
update content because they have so much
of it and there's so much activity there
for example smaller agency may only have
one person that updates contact uh
content on the website so so that that
happens um based on the agency and and
their Staffing level and what their
business needs are uh so there's no one
uh one answer to that okay represent
blackis thank you um could you send the
to the committee email uh if you have a
mockup image whatever of the template
that you you're recommending for the
various Departments of what their the
web pages should look like sure once we
get it U I think the Department of
Transportation is really close to what
we're going to you know they what they
have now is pretty I think is compliant
with this language so I'll I'll double
check that and we'll we'll point you at
okay thank you madam Cher so morning
commissioner good morning I mean it
occurs to me that that we are undergoing
a fundamental uh switch and change from
a society where the
for decades ever since the telephone
became ver virtually uniform Universal I
meant to say in the country where you
first thing you did was you picked up
your telephone you dial the name of the
company and and you try to get a hold of
a person okay and those of us who are
longtime
adults uh we've been trained by
the existence existing Society to do it
that way and relatively suddenly we are
in a different situation where that
doesn't work anymore very well because
companies do not want to have people
call them in my
opinion because you got you have to have
a very elaborate Network to hand handle
a tremendous influx of requests for
information and help
right and now we have a situation where
you have to look something up on a
website and so what is
the the degree of
uniformity if you could just tell us
that currently because I'm sure you're
striving for much greater uniformity so
that when people look some something up
as representative Brown has been doing
and and I go online and look stuff up
I'm sure most of us do and the first
thing we look for is how to get in touch
with
somebody um but I I think that the web
the websites web pages generally are
trying to get the people to find the
information on the web on the web page
yes and your question is
so I you've been talking about this but
where are we in terms of
converting uh
the the the to the existing you've
already described in your testimony that
uh that it's being currently being done
agency by agency right that that is not
user friendly for the people it would be
much better to have uniformity so that
something there's always a first step
and and if it's going to be that contact
button
uh I predict that that
will uh that will not
work but it will be be where people are
going to
go commissioner um so I think what
you're saying and I I would tend to
agree I think step one was uniformity in
how we represent our agency websites to
me the next step would be you know
aggregating content in a way that was
not agency specific which is I think
what you just said in fact we have a
procurement out there right now for a
business services portal that we're
doing a competitive procurement and that
would you know the vision there would be
to take you know this business services
that could be delivered from multiple
agencies and house them in a single
place in an easy way and organize them
by business type or what they call Web
Geeks call it Persona I am I'm a car I'm
a car dealer at a titled person at Bley
Chevrolet have certain things I care
about that's what I should see when I go
there so I think that's what you're
talking about we don't have uh funding I
I'd love to U work on um a citizen
portal that was similar in other words
you you have somebody coming in who's a
certain you know uh type of person and
then we present content to them that's
specific to them regardless of what
agency it's coming from that's a great
vision some states are doing that many
are not we aren't yet but but it is a
good it would be a good good thing to do
and and we're starting on the business
side of that with that business services
portal procurement um I I also wanted to
answer the question from grip Dolan
around the the voice activated um we're
going to one of the nice things about
our content platform now is it's it's
standards-based open source uh some
people care about that and um and um
it's changing as part of our service so
as as what's the norm evolves from a
website perspective I think it'll be
pretty easy for us to adapt to that
follow
up a follow-up question thank you um so
one of the things that I'm experiencing
in my Outreach um um is uh a
portal concept we that word hasn't been
mentioned yet this morning I believe um
and the hospitals for example or health
care services they are many of them
maybe all of them now I haven't been to
all of them thank God but but uh they
are they have a portals and and um the
Democratic office has a portal as well
uh so is that something that is kind of
one of
the strategies you're already following
can you speak to that yes in fact um
that procurement that's out there now um
we're working with the Bea on that uh
that's the we call it the business
services portal and that would be a
place where um you know businesses we V
our vision is where business would go to
have you know um content that they may
care about without having to hunt it
down in an agency
website thank
you represent of gold thank you madam
chair and thank you commissioner for
taking my question if I understand
correctly what I'm hearing you say is
that you have three um employees who are
able to code or um handle things on for
the website that basically are handling
the main
um Conformity across state agencies and
then within each agency there are people
who can manipulate data within that
agency to uh to keep it agency specific
for the variety that's needed to cover
their agency and then when there are big
projects like business portals or um I'm
sure that you could name us 500 L your
list of requests from the various
agencies that are
prioritized um when those come in those
are contracted out thus the request if
you want something really complicated
it's going to cost money is that correct
yes it it it it's almost exactly correct
in fact in fact as we're moving sites to
the new design structure one of the
things we're suggesting is that agencies
go through that effort of identifying
Persona and then organizing their
content um around Persona which is a
non-trivial task it's not a technical
task it's a it's a Brute Force effort uh
but it it it it works really well and
you can see that reflected in some of
the newer websites like if you were to
take a look Environmental Services or do
or the education sites that those and U
or HHS some of the newer sites there
they've they've invested in that um in
some of the smaller sites are relatively
simple there may only be one Persona so
it doesn't require that
complexity um the that K bringing in
outside expertise to help with that can
can can be good because um not all
humans are programmed to think think
like your customers so that's one of the
things about that to do a good website
you really don't want to use your own
opinion about what's good or not you
want to use the opinion of those folks
who are going to be accessing the
website to determine whether we're doing
well or
not
follow so getting back to this bill what
I think I hear you say is that if if the
intent here is simply which I would
support 100% to make contact clear at
the top right hand corner that's
something that your staff can do and
that'll translate on that main template
all across all agencies right and and
the reason I asked for more time is
we're we're working on the remaining 20
some percent of websites and if we made
that a standard it would come you know
they wouldn't cost anything extra we'd
just do it as part of transferring those
sites from their old format to the
new thank you questions
MRA py thank you madam chair thank you
for taking another question I have two
part one is the content relevancy and
how quickly the content changes and also
with the communication interf phasing is
there a chat option that comes of how
can I help you kind of thing
um with the contact and communication
with the customers
so um we uh agencies have experimented
with chat Bots which I think is what
you're asking about we don't really have
any um broad deployment of that it
actually takes a
um it's interesting it takes a different
psychology and it's just I think maybe
where you're getting at is to implement
a good chatbot is not it's not an FAQ
it's not question answer it has to have
some intelligence and you can't just
throw it out
there you have to watch watch it
carefully and help it learn how to serve
our customers better so that's the
coaching I give to agencies who are
considering a chatbot is that they have
to assign people to to watching the
metrics watching how often it solves a
problem or not and addressing those
problems right away which is is is a
commitment um it it it it hearkens back
a little bit to social media early days
of social media when when entities were
putting up social media links they
weren't watching their own social media
link links which made them kind of nonv
valuable and even potentially harmful
and and chats the same way so my
coaching to agencies is chat chat bot
can be a really good thing as long as we
pay attention to it and it has been has
not been broadly adopted in the state
yet in the executive
branch thank you representative gold
thank you one last question uh
commissioner So within the rated items
of change requests that you have to the
system where would add a contact button
to the top right corner across all pages
fall in my priority list well um if it's
made
important um I it's already been made
important to me so I'm going to we're
you know I've talked to the folks that
run this and we're like oh yeah we can
do that so it's it would be high in in
the priority list thank you
right seeing no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on House Bill
1606 all right not seeing any I will
close the public hearing and open the
hearing on House Bill
Corman
thank you madam chair uh for those who
don't remember from 20 and one a half
hours ago I am Tom Corman uh I represent
Grafton 15 which is Ward three of the
city of
Lebanon uh before I talk about the bill
I just want to give you a little
background about myself to establish my
Bona fitas in the area as they were I am
an Emeritus professor of computer
science at Dartmouth College I was on
the faculty there for 29 and a half
years I retired off cycle I chaired the
computer science department for six
years from
2019 uh excuse me 2009 to
2015 I've been in computer science since
1974 you don't need a computer to do the
math and realize that's 50 years so I've
been doing this stuff for a long time I
have uh eecs electrical engineering and
computer science degrees my undergrad
from Princeton a BSE and a master's in
PhD from
MIT I am actually best known as the lead
author of a textbook called introduction
to algorithms it is a 1300 plus page
textbook on computer algorithms it is
the standard computer algorithms
textbook in computer science it is the
best known book in all of computer
science we've sold over 1 million copies
of this worldwide in ious translations
and I know for a fact that at least one
member of this committee owns a
copy that said I did not do research in
in artificial intelligence AI uh but I
had to keep up with developments in AI
in large part because as the chair of
the computer science department I needed
to keep up with the entire field and
understand what was going on and what I
do know is that AI has made astounding
progress in the last few years when I
was in graduate at school in the 1980s
AI just seemed dead in the water the big
thing was expert systems where you would
actually encode knowledge into a system
and then the system could answer
questions about it and it would be
really Arcane stuff for example there
was a system called cats and maybe with
a number it had nothing to do with cats
it was about locomotive repair so you
know doesn't get much more Arcane and
locomotive repair but what we've seen in
the last few years is that we have what
are called Deep neural Nets neural Nets
have been around for a long time but
people finally figured out how to use
them and something called large language
models where you're training these
systems on a a huge Corpus possibly the
whole internet now I'm a quantitative
guy I know math I know what exponential
means and I know that people often
misuse exponential to mean fast growing
I know what exponential really means and
I think the progress in AI really has
been exponential it really has been
something something but there's a big
concern which is bias in artificial
intelligence systems and that's due in
large part to the bias in the data that
the neural Nets are trained on whatever
data set you give there's going to be
some inherent bias so I'm really
concerned about Artificial Intelligence
impinging on our rights especially in
the face of the the potential of biased
algorithms not just the potential but
the reality of biased algorithms
so I drafted this bill hb1 1688 to
protect the rights of granite Staters
from AI systems now I modeled it on two
pieces of legislation there's a lot of
legislation out there and if you get the
same new Fe news feeds I do you know
that uh various states are looking at Ai
and in fact various committees in our
house are looking at bills related to
AI I modeled this on legislation in
Connecticut and and also the European
Union but I tailored it to New Hampshire
the bill is about protecting the rights
of granite Staters from AI systems used
by state agencies it places no
restrictions on anyone or anything else
including private Enterprise and the
co-sponsors if you look at the
co-sponsors they really represent a
broad spectrum of political thought uh
because we all want to protect
everyone's rights the bill exempts
systems used by state funded
institutions of Higher Learning I have
friends at UNH and I don't want to
prevent them from doing re research in
AI so it's not about research it's not
about universities it's about the state
agencies uh and also it exempts any
systems in common personal use so uh one
of the things that the bill talks about
is facial recognition well if you're
using facial recognition to unlock your
smartphone that's not under the the bill
right that's a personal system in common
use that's it's not a state agency using
it for something so the bill defines uh
three terms AI artificial int
intelligence generative Ai and deep
fakes so it defines AI as the ability of
a machine to display humanlike
capabilities for cognitive tasks such as
reasoning learning planning and
creativity and that AI can adapt Its
Behavior by analyzing the effects of
previous actions and operating under
varying and unpredictable circumstan an
es without human oversight now I do want
to say that I've sent this bill out to
various people and one of the people I
sent it to is a man named Ronald revest
who's one of my co-authors on the
textbook he's also a touring Award
winner the touring award is like the
Nobel Prize of computer science uh he
knows of stuff and he suggested uh maybe
say that they may adapt their behavior
rather than they can adapt their
behavior but what's I think really
important about the definition of AI
that I gave compared with where you see
it in other bills and other places is
that I've defined AI only in terms of
behavior of the system not in terms of
its implementation you will see if you
look at bills from other states where
they talk about neural Nets and training
I'm not defining it that way I'm just
saying it's systems that behave in a
certain way regardless of how they're
implemented because implementations are
going to change over time generative AI
is AI that can generate text images or
other media in response to prompts um
chat
GPT um uh Dolly things like that and a
deep fake uh the bill defines as a video
in which a person's face or body is
digitally altered so that they appear to
be someone else saying something they
never said or doing something that they
never did and I realize uh oh and it
it's typically used maliciously or to
spread false information but not always
you know I I could imagine you know we
put out a PSA of Abraham Lincoln talking
about preventing forest fires or
something like that but typically
they're used maliciously and actually as
I think about it uh the the bill
actually says video but it could apply
to any media right for example um as we
all know Joe Biden didn't really call up
people and say to not vote on primary
day and that wasn't video that was
audio so the bill has prohibited uses by
state agencies and these are drawn again
from the Connecticut bill and the EU
restrictions
uh so the first thing that's listed is
cognitive behavioral manipulation now I
heard from uh commissioner goule of the
state it a uh Department yesterday that
there may be cases where we do want
cognitive behavioral manipulation and he
gave a great example of a uh a veteran
calling a a helpline and the helpline
actually directs the veteran to the
right place using AI so I can imagine
making some sort of amendment uh for
that that or maybe removing it uh
classifying People based on Behavior
socioeconomic status or personal
characteristics resulting in unlawful
discrimination or disperate impact based
on actual or perceived
characteristics real time and remote
biometric identification for public
surveillance such as facial recognition
and the bill has an exception for
locating a missing or abducted person
and again uh commissioner goule gave me
another case where we actually might
want to use surveillance and uh imagine
a school shooting where we want to
actually figure out where the shooter is
so again I can imagine um a another
restriction on that and then deep fakes
when used for any deceptive or malicious
purpose so those would be prohibited and
then the bill has uses that are
permitted but with
restrictions if an AI system produces a
recommendation or a decision that once
you execute you can't undo it then there
must be an appropriate human in the loop
and an example that I think of is
imagine a hostage situation and the
state police send in a robot the robot
does not decide what to do right if the
robot shoots someone there's no way to
unsho them so I would want an
appropriate human in the loop um other
examples when rights and freedoms of an
individual are determined uh again this
is where there has to be a human in the
loop uh biometric identification
to verify identity management and
operation of critical infrastructure
state and local law enforcement actions
and interpreting and applying laws
including sentencing and we know that
elsewhere AI has proven biased in s
sentencing so sentencing should not be
done only by AI the bill also says that
if you have material produced by
generative AI without a human in the
loop that must be disclosed as generated
by AI I and that whenever a human is
interacting with AI directly or
indirectly they must be told that they
are you need to know if you're
interacting with AI rather than a
person the bill also has a section on
compliance uh it says that within nine
months of the effective date All State
agencies must report compliance to the
Department of Information Technology
reviewing Ai and systems to verify
compliance removing any AI not in
compliance and modifying all procedures
relative to AOG
sorry modifying um all procedures
relative to AI as um as needed to be in
compliance and any new AI systems need
to comply and one year after the
effective date of the ACT uh the
department of it would produce a report
summarizing what state agencies have
done with
AI
now one question that I hope is in your
mind is why a bill for this why why
can't we do this with what we have the
uh Department of Information Technology
already has New Hampshire state
government code of ethics for the use
and development of generative artificial
intelligence and automated decision
systems and it does overlap with uh some
of the areas in the bill but the bill
goes beyond that but the main thing is
this the bill is about rights it's about
our rights and our citizens rights it
should be enshrined in statute not just
administrative rules administrative
rules can change quickly or when a new
Administration comes in so I really feel
like whatever rights we want to have to
protect our citizens from AI should be
in
statute uh so there are other suggested
changes that I've heard from people and
uh the main thing is I'm happy to work
with the committee or subcommittee and
with agencies on any amendments to
improve the bill it's not an early bill
so we do have have some time to work on
it and with that I'm happy to take
questions thank you represent Dolan and
then Schmidt and man goody thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for taking my question
uh my my concern is specifically about
election interference and you mentioned
one with President Biden was a victim of
uh of some already uh my question
is uh have you intersected with our
committee on Election law that's also
working on some bills on AI and has they
how they relate to elections thank you
uh I'm actually a co-sponsor on that
bill that representative Brennan has has
is the prime sponsor for and actually I
know of bills in at least four
committees related to AI um so what one
of the things that we need to do is is
look at at AI holistically take a a
broader view of AI rather than committee
by committee and I've actually spoken
with chairman Roy of Criminal Justice
and Public Safety about that and there
may be something that we can do but I
don't know that that's going to happen
anytime soon so I think for now we're
going to have to go with this peacemeal
approach committee by committee but
you're right we do need for example a
standard definition of AI in statute not
RSA by
RSA follow up follow up uh committee
chair Perry has is is has that that
other bill in the election law just as a
point of reference that if you want to
talk to him about it thank you madam
chair okay thank you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so
question number one of the chair is this
subcommittee if we think it needs it yes
I it's up to
me this is a dipping our toe into the
Atlantic ocean instead of just the
bathtub um so probably yes yeah thank
you uh Professor Corman if I may so uh
the thing is um is there a component in
your bill setting up a study committee
because th this really
is getting into a whole Terror
incognit the bill that I submitted does
not set up a study committee um I spoke
with chairman Roy
about a study committee one one of the
things he had suggested was that uh the
speaker set up a special committee on AI
and apparently speaker is not interested
in doing that at this time so another
suggestion was to take a bill that's
currently in committee somewhere and
have it set up uh a study commission not
just a committee but a commission that
would have experts from outside the
legislature we certainly have plenty of
people people within the state who are
more knowledgeable about AI than any of
us in the building here uh so that would
be one possibility but my bill doesn't
do that just a quick follow so we you
you could submit an amendment to this
bill that would that would establish
such a study committee we we could do
that I know there's also a bill in
judiciary uh that that is about Ai and
Judiciary maybe doing something like
that so what I think we need to do if if
we're going to do that we need to make
sure that we're Co coordinating among
the Committees to make sure that we
don't have five bills that are setting
up a
commission yes thank you for that
thought representative maputi thank you
madam chair uh very specific to system
approach to computer in computer
technology field things change very
rapidly right it used to be twoe cycle
and six month cycle now two week cycle
kind of thing so how far
behind is the entire computer system in
the state that are all the Departments
connected with the same technology
infrastructure that's needed to handle
this
leap representative I
think commissioner gulay might be a
better person to answer that question to
be honest with you right but I I I I
will say that um the way the bill is
written it's really technology
independent that that's why I was very
careful to craft it to define AI in
terms of behavior rather than technology
or
implementation uh I I will also say that
we had a bill last year that would have
set up a uh a it would have said that
the uh there's there is an IT Advisory
Board I believe and they meet twice a
year and it would have had them looking
at Ai and that came to to my committee
science technology and energy and uh we
recommended itl on that bill and it was
ited um because with things moving so
fast that that Council or or or board
meets only twice a year which isn't fast
enough okay representative broa thank
you I have a comment to the chair um I
think this bill is Well written I don't
believe it needs to go to committee but
if you want to do that that's your
prerogative I just think he needs a
couple
of you know fixes that um representative
Corman rep um recommended to us and I'll
be glad to take that on if you wish
thank you we will we've got two other
people who wish to speak so we'll see
what they have to say about
it okay other questions thank you very
Maguire
thank you very much Madam chair and
Happy Valentine's Day to you and the
rest of the committee um as you as you
may recall I represent the town of
Epsom and uh while I'm not quite as
accomplished as representative Corman I
too uh received the PhD in computer
science from MIT 30 plus years
ago and um I'm happy to be a co-sponsor
of this bill um you know despite my
background I've never been what you
might call an early
adopter I I tend to have a go slow
approach to technology and that's sort
of how I see this bill as telling the
state you know let's go slow and be
careful uh we got something new here
we don't have to be way out in front we
can we can be slow we can be thoughtful
and so on um I think the key part of the
bill is um on the first page line
24 the prohibition
section um uh representative Corman
already talked about the first one
behavioral um manipulation that might
need slight um slight Amendment to sort
of informational purposes and and
possibly therapeutic
purposes um but the one that I think is
key is on the second page number Roman
three um surveillance type of stuff and
so I think that's very much in line with
our latest uh change to the Constitution
regarding privacy um I I think I think
that's excellent and obviously number
five uh deceptive and malicious stuff
you know that that's very important um
in general I would assume or you know I
would be very surprised to learn if the
state is in violation of any of these
things currently right so so I think I
think this is kind of ahead of the curve
this is just to make sure we don't
accidentally kind of step off the off
the edge and into these kind of things
but I I would assume that you know it's
it's be relatively quick to to discover
you know to just to you know determine
that we're not in in violation here um
and if so to to clean up those one or
two small cases but I'm happy to answer
questions Schmid thank you madam
chair uh so your statement you don't
think that the state is probably in
violation but how about private entities
and should we not be thinking about that
as well thank you for the question
representative this bill does not as as
representative Corman said this bill is
not about private action this is
actions question follow up well that's
my question if if it's much more it
would be certainly pernicious if the
state were yeah heavy-handedly involved
but to the degree that private entities
um are are almost certainly doing that
already uh should we not be mindful of
some way of getting at that yeah all
right thank you for the question so in
general I would say no um because I
think we already have sort of General
Provisions for example on um uh the
first page line 26 classifying People
based on Behavior Etc notice that that
sub paragraph A and B both start with
the word unlawful so we already have
Provisions that people can't un
unlawfully discriminate based on you
know the the laundry list of of
characteristics so um so the answer is
is sort of to me is no I think let's
start with this and and sort of see how
it
goes other
questions all right thank you very much
excuse me representative gold has a
question just one quick one a little
concerned about a peac meal
approach and I want to thank all of you
for bringing this to our attention
because this is huge and it's important
and I love getting ahead of the
eightball but I'm not convinced we are
ahead of it but um my question has to do
with do you think that one bigger
centralized approach I would serve the
state better than a peace meal approach
yeah thank you for the question so I
think you have in mind you know a
director of AI or something of that sort
maybe um so no I I guess I don't think
so I I really like I agree with
representative groa that this is a very
well-written bill I think uh
representative Corman did a very careful
simple but my question had to do with
the possibility there was talk that they
were like four other bills and we could
have four different peac meal bills
happening um thank you for the question
I'm I'm only personally familiar with
one of them there's a bill in election
law uh to pre which I am also a
co-sponsor of which is to prevent
deceptive advertising so similar to that
um Roman 4 but but in the in the realm
of political advertising
so I again I think that this bill is is
strictly about um State actions right
things that the state would do on its
own whereas these other bills have more
to do with the the the public and and
the political Arena and so on so it's
it's appropriate to have more than one I
I don't think it's that bad okay anyone
else thank you very much for your
testimony director
gay commissioner GLE
sorry
good morning again uh Madam chair
members of the committee uh Dennis goule
the commissioner for the Department of
Information
Technology um I'm here today to uh
testify in opposition to this bill I'll
I'll I'll explain that as I as as I go
uh but first of all I I want to say that
um I think U representative Corman and
myself share passion for for doing AI
correctly um it's one of the reasons why
the state of New Hampshire was one of
the very first states in the union to
have a code of ethics which is passing
around and and a policy for agencies to
to
follow um I'll I'll take uh a couple of
a moment to to talk about a couple
things first I think the the compliance
section is is not feasible to implement
or enforce uh the the executive branch
is running hundreds of application
Solutions many of the vendors are adding
AI capabilities right now as we speak to
their platforms and despite that we're
seeing no impetus to transgress our AI
our existing code of ethics or policies
on the behalf of the agencies in fact
what I'm seeing from a our agency
partner Partners is they're coming to us
and asking about things they're saying
well you know what we're thinking about
AI what should we be doing and that's
part of how we came up with the we were
talking earlier about the chatbots and
how you do that appropriately well a lot
of the chatbot technology is using you
know generative AI
capabilities um so really I'm I'm not
really expecting to have a problem here
um the uh and the the other thing is is
the
uh that rep Corman talked about you know
the speed at which we have to adapt
that's one of the things I like about
having the policy no sooner did I did we
publish this policy that I found a flaw
in it and we quickly corrected it and uh
so uh it's one of the things that is
nice about H doing it this way um as
pointed out and as I shared with the
sponsor um the some of the language is
is prescribing things that could be good
you know we have the example of somebody
who's who's coming on to a suicide
hotline chatbot we're trying to
influence their behavior we're trying to
make sure that they do the right thing
for themselves and their loved ones um
the other thing is is that the uh
particularly on the facial recognition
side um that's you know for um the
Departments of safety and and and
Corrections that can be a strong Public
Safety tool that we can use and and I
I'd hate to see that not be allowed um
the other thing is is it's missing
important things like one of the AI
algorithms can't do anything without
data data is what educates them to
actually generate some sort some form of
artificial intelligence and so
protecting the Citizen's
data is you the data that we're char
charged with holding is is an important
part of what we need to be doing so
that's one of the reasons why we have
Provisions in our in our contract
language templates that that talk about
the you know not um using our data for
purposes outside of the the state of New
Hampshire what we're what we're um um
what we're purchasing that technology
for there would be a strong motivation
for technology vendors to want to gather
more and more data because that will
educate their Ai and make it work better
we don't want that as it relates to
State of New Hampshire data so there's a
piece missing as well and and that
really leads me to uh my my final
conclusion and and I think you know
there may be a time when we need AI to
to regulate state
agencies um I don't feel like we're
there at this point um for reasons I
mentioned before but but but also um I'd
like to I'd like to feel like i' I've
been following this in watching this and
feel pretty well educated and I still
feel like we're learning stuff really
rapidly and I'd want to have the ability
to adapt quickly and not have to wait
for a legislative session to change what
AI first and of leus and then M thank
you um
so I you know obviously haven't had a
chance to read the documents he handed
out but if they they are very good then
I would expect that there's not a
problem we're not going to be in
conflict with it I'm just going to so I
don't know so the question is why do you
feel that you know you need to oppose
this
bill and related to that questions about
why You' oppose it um I know there's
concerns about privacy and and having
this expanded law enforcement is a big
concern and there's there are probably
going to be an amendment to some of the
things that that you talked about but um
if you'd respond to that sure I think
the speed to adapt is my my largest
thing right now is um the uh you know
having the ability to if we discover
that there's flaws in how we're thinking
about Ai and regulating it inside the
state then I'd like to be a little doubt
quickly followup followup um but I mean
what makees sense to
um you as as one of the speakers before
said you know slow things down um put a
um and and think about this carefully
because if we done this path there there
could be problems and you wanted to you
had some things you said about um you
know protecting information all that but
I don't see anything in the bill that
would prevent you from doing that is am
I incorrect no the I think the main
point there
was arguing that I don't think we know
as much as we need to know to to um
regulate Ai and statute yet but I would
ha I'd be happy to collaborate with the
committee or subcommittee or or study
committee if if we want to go that that
way and kind of work on it uh but all
right thank you represent man py thank
you madam chair thank you uh director
for taking my question have to part in
terms of when web page became a central
piece
and the ethics and code of ethics and
how to manage when you put up a web P
web safety all those things were
critical piece
when uh Society transitioned to web page
are we not there for AI at this point if
we wait we have to have the ethics and
infrastructure whether we are ready or
not the train is in the station if you
get on the train or not it's going to go
so does that make the
re reason that we have to address it now
technology is
here yes yes and and and I feel like we
are addressing it um we're we're
actively engaging with the agencies that
are thinking about using AI technology
and we're looking we're looking to guide
them in the appropriate use of that
and through our through our policies um
and I agree the train has is very
rapidly leaving the station as I
testified before if you look at the
major software platforms that we're
running in the state or about to run all
of them are adding AI capabilities and
most of them are actually doing their
own codes of Ethics because a for
software companies or or technology
platform companies in for for the most
part they're it's not going to be in
their interest for for their customers
to misuse that technology will just
reflect badly on them so we're seeing
our major technology Partners bringing
in their customers and saying here's
what our AI code of ethics is and you
know it's it's baby steps for them and I
certainly wouldn't trust them to do
everything we need to do but that is
happening as well glad to know there are
some baby steps representative Schmidt
and then thank you madam chair so uh
could you be more specific in your
opposition is it that this bill is
fundamentally wrongheaded uh going in
the wrong direction or is it flawed and
it needs some fixes that you could help
us with no I think I I think the
sponsors and I are mostly in agreement I
think it's more of for for me it's a
timing
thing thank you representative laus um
so I'm wondering if you can understand
or you have a you know some comment on
the idea that the the fact that um the
platform vendors are adding AI
um generates I think a serious concern
and uh is something that uh we should
breaks put the brakes on and the
legislature needs to oversee how this
stuff is added I mean I was a little you
know anyway so is there some reason why
that's not
reasonable no I mean it's your
prerogative and I I respect that
prerogative um I would argue that we
are we are acting in your interest and
in the citizens interest already um but
but you may not agree with that and and
again that's your prerogative thank you
representative Simon and then goalie
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking my question um and I would start
by saying I'm not sure that anybody
questions whether you're keeping our
best interest at heart um I think the
question that keeps coming to my mind as
uh I'm listening to my colleagues
questions and your answers to them um
there are obviously a few components
that are of concern as mentioned um the
committee is interested in in amending
those things to address those concerns
outside of those specific concerns
however I guess but at least I haven't
understood or haven't heard from you um
what about this document do you think
would slow or impede your ability to
address issues in the future what about
this would slow you down outside of
those because I I I'm personally not
seeing it okay I well I'm not seeing it
either I just I I what when we what I
the history of of my what I've seen as
we've approached things like cyber
security for example um years ago when I
joined the state um we uh did an
executive order on cyber security and we
thought about asking for legislation and
we thought oh um we don't understand it
that well yet so let's do an EO and then
put the things that are important that
we learn in statute so what we learned
is some of the stuff we assumed were was
correct in the executive order was was
and some was not and we've added things
to statute since then in a thoughtful
way that has helped us a lot with the
state's cyber security posture so I'm
not saying I know of things that but in
particular if there's language and
statute that would preclude us from
adapting to things we learn um it would
be you know that it's it's another cycle
to get that
corrected
so just to make sure that I'm clear it
seemed clear but you're saying you can't
see anything specifically wrong with
this bill at the moment but we just
don't know what we so if we worked on
amendments and passed this um I don't it
I don't think it would harm the state in
the short term we just you know I feel
like that the Train's left the station
it is moving at exceptionally
fastpac and um I I have this niggling
concern that that you know we could put
language in in statute that may um cause
us to not be able to adapt quickly
enough
that's that's all okay thank you
representative goalie and then
Brown thank you madam chair and thank
you for addressing that part because
that's one of my concerns is why we
always don't like to put things into
statute because we know how long it can
take to change that statute if need be
um but I just wanted to reach out and
reading
your uh code of ethics and I heard from
the sponsor um that in this bill he was
using the uh European guidelines as well
as some of Connecticut's statutes I
believe but I just wanted to touch
upon letting us know how much of the
European Union guidelines you're using
because I was surprised to see that
that's right here in your guidelines the
same yeah guidelines he's looking for in
his legislation that you already are
adopting right could you just exp they
using the guidelines as a whole or just
in
part um I can't I I can't answer that
question I I don't know the I don't know
the all of the details to give you a a
factual answer on that but we we are
leveraging those guidelines U for for
our efforts I don't know that we're
using the whole of
them
representative Brown thank you madam
chair thanks for taking my question
going back to something you said I don't
know if you if if it was an example is
there actually a suicide hotline that's
managed by a chat
box Chad bot well it's it's actually not
in in state in state um government but
um there is a a
veteran's hot line yeah in which case in
which case we can't do anything about it
yeah no I and I I just I wanted to use
that as an example because we could do
that right we you know 211 made for
example decide to start using technology
that would help in that way and um I
don't know that they're that they're
they are intending to do that but just
an
example okay or possibly 511 could uh
decide to direct people to side roads
instead of the main roads or whatever
represent
gold thank you thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my
question my earlier question regarding
the peacemeal nature of bills or
legislation around AI having you know
this stuff all travels at the speed of
light I agree and my
experience in the state of New Hampshire
and it is very ancient compared to the
speed of but I I know
that the system was done peace me and
then you came in and had to take over
these these bits and pieces and try to
create one cohesive system and that's a
little bit of where my concern is coming
in if we have multiple bills coming in
addressing the topic of I really like
the idea of being ahead of the eightball
and and I like the idea of of a
commission that can assist you of with
all this expertise that can stay
flexible and and keep a breast so I'd
like your thoughts about that if you had
an IT Commission not an office a paid
office but one of our our uh volunteer
commissions do you think that would be
beneficial to your three-man office in
making these decisions and moving ahead
well the the three person office is is
for just the website stuff so we have a
you know a large Department looking at
this and and and paying attention to
this and it's really top of mind not
just for New Hampshire doit but for all
it all state government it in fact the
National Association of State Chief
Information officers um is really
focused on on AI right now and how we
how we manage correctly through the
process of of dealing with this
technology Revolution that's occurring
but the the types of bills that are out
there around the country are twofold
most of them are Public public policy
Focus like the
election bill that we're talking about
and and in that case you know it really
doesn't fall into anything I have a
right as a commissioner to have an
opinion on but I think that we're seeing
large impacts with AI from a public
policy perspective and it's certainly
you know something that we need to
address I um probably sooner than later
um inward inwardly facing is my
perspective here and and and again I I
think we really need to pay attention we
really need to adapt quickly um there as
well
I I feel like the management structure
that exists inside doit is adequate to
to continue to manage on a policy level
for the executive branch thank you
you're welcome representative
Simon thank you madam chair thank you
for clarification on the last question
just a a slight bit more clarification
on kind of follow up on my my last
question I'm trying to work my way
through
this when you talk about the need to
respond to things quickly um I feel like
there's there's two things that that
could apply to that that is
implementation by the state of AI
processes right so we're going to use AI
we're going to implement it for
different reasons and the the second in
my mind would be to protect our
constituents against AI from the outside
um it seems to me that we'd have to be
able to respond quickly in protecting
against AI from the
outside but it seems to me this bill is
mostly dealing with our own
implementation of AI why would we need
to be able to respond Qui quickly to our
own implementation of AI wouldn't be
more prudent to be as has been spoken
more cautious about that because we
don't necessarily need to be on The
Cutting Edge of it U so I'm just
wondering what your mindset I yeah so I
I didn't explain myself well but I'm I
don't feel the need to move quickly in
the implementation of AI in state
government and we we're traditionally
pretty conservative uh the and that's
reflected on how the agencies operate as
it relates to
technology um so I'm not seeing a large
impetus to implement AI stuff inside
State inside uh the agencies so um but
as our as our partners add technology
technology that any person inside the
executive branch could potentially
Implement um I want to I want to be able
to adapt to that quickly in terms
of guidelines around usage that would
not
transgress um you
know our citizens rights the rights of
the people that come visit in Hamp how
whatever so that's really what I was
thinking okay thank you for the
clarification you're welcome other
questions pres
Schmid thank you madam chair so it was
referenced earlier but we didn't get
really get into it uh the idea of uh
rules being somewhat faster than statuto
things but are there currently any rules
that you're working on I mean they have
to have a statute to underpin them of
course but do you feel you have the the
uh the current authority to promulgate
rules in this direction that you are
working on as a member of the jelar I'm
wondering U well actually we we we don't
actually have Ru making Authority per se
in doit but what we do have is through
the through the action of the um
Information Technology Council we can um
Implement policy which then has the
force of law so um that's how how we
operate so the excuse me your policy has
the force of
law if it it there's um there's um
language in in 21r that allows I I
probably that was probably too strong a
way to State it my apologies
but
we can enforce policy inside the
executive branch um through the um
actions of the it Council and the IT
council is itself in statute it's the
the wording is a little
bit you know am ambiguous
but thank you you're welcome other
questions thank you very much all right
thank you I think this will be going to
subcommittee there's more stuff popping
up than then we need to look
at uh is there anyone else who wishes to
1688 all right seeing none I will close
the public hearing this will be going to
one's
prohibitions
good morning or good afternoon welcome
to Edna I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill
1456 and call Representative
Walsh good afternoon Madam chair thank
you um for the record my name is
representative Tom Walsh uh from marac
10 which are the towns of hookit and D
Bon and I'm here today to introduce
House Bill
um uh this issue was brought to me by
the way thank you for having me in Edna
I've been here for 12 years and I've
never been before this committee so it's
it's an honor uh this is usually outside
my wheelhouse too uh but this was
brought to me by um a constituent about
an issue with the land and tax appeals
and as it turns out the housing appeals
board in terms of when it it's required
or needed to have somebody uh removed
from from either one of them uh as I
looked into it I noticed that uh the
both of the boards were
currently um appointed by the Supreme
Court and that's fine it was clear but
when you get to the removal which is 71
B3 or
6793 language is very similar it was
just very vague on who actually did the
removing um so looking for a solution um
I thought about it for a bit and I
actually spoke with with representative
Lynn who was on the Supreme Court and I
and I said well you know both boards
actually operate on a quasi
judicial uh Manner and I said the
governor and Council actually do the
appointing for the the uh for the judges
why wouldn't they do the same thing he
agreed and he uh was also willing to
co-sponsor it for those reasons um so
that's all the bill does it moves the
appointment and the removal of both land
and tax tax appeals board housing
appeals board um to the council the
governor and councel um and again I
you've got it in front of you so I don't
need to do all the references but uh
4.1 uh actually was added to both of
those sections for the removal uh which
does just that um I did get
unfortunately representative Lynn
couldn't make it today he's got another
uh hearing going on uh he does uh he did
ask me to state that he does fully
support this this uh he did have a
suggestion for an amendment that uh
possibly wouldn't affect the current
members of these boards if you do think
A change is uh is
required um and I guess there are some
people here with some proposed
suggestions for an amendment beyond that
uh for me I'm just trying to see that
the um um the the removal process gets
cleared up and that's pretty much all I
care hope to see so in your wisdom uh
any changes you see or find with me
that's all I've got well thank you we'll
take full advantage of that I'm
sure any questions represent laus yeah I
just have a I I see that what was handed
out includes a uh proposed amendment and
I haven't had a chance to look through
it in detail but what from it is it
just grandfathering in the current
people or what is this amendment doing
and is this
yours thank you for the question
representative that's not not mine I
just received it about a minute before
you did uh but I know there was somebody
signed up to speak behind me who can
explain it thank
you okay anyone else for representative
right and stmc and
um which which of the uh representatives
of the btla would be most appropriate to
be first
okay they you're Michelle LeBrun and
yeah my name is Michelle LeBrun and I
think Eric wishes to speak
first good afternoon Madam chair and
honorable members of this committee
thank you for taking the opportun
affording US the opportunity to speak
this with you this afternoon
be
better my apologies sir good afternoon
thank you for the opportunity to address
this honorable committee this afternoon
my name is Eric wind I am a recently
appointed member of the board um and we
also have the member Walker and the
board clerk with us as well to answer
any questions um we wanted to be here
today to address certain aspects of this
proposed legislation and the fact that
we do agree that there is a need to
improve the appointment process as and
the removal
process um the appointment process at
present does not afford any statutory
opportunity to the public to be involved
to give comment or for a hearing and the
removal process is is ambiguous as to
which branch of government would take
the lead on removing a member so those
are the two key
issues in the amendment we do propose a
intermediary step to replacing the
Supreme Court entirely in the
appointment
process um and so I do want to briefly
comment on that that that is an
alternative that we would encourage this
committee to consider given the duties
of the board and the important role that
the board plays in taxation here in New
Hampshire um and that that's there for
your consideration that
the a new member of the board would be
nominated by the Supreme Court would be
the alternative that we would ask you to
consider but still go through a full GNC
hearing
process
um and then on the removal
aspect
the the amendment does take the language
out of
RSA 71-b colon 2 and inserts it into an
existing provision related to removal
located
71-b colon 3 but it otherwise it does
not substantively change the proposal
which is to conform the standard of
removal with RSA
41 and then lastly there is also a
technical note that currently board
members serve three years and the terms
are not staggered for two of us and so
as you're in this legislation working on
that that's a technical fix that we do
recommend that you change so that terms
do not expire at the same time and and
we also recommend the terms be extended
to 5 years so it's comparable with the
housing appeals board and other
statutory
tribunals um so I'm available to take
questions but at this time I'll turn the
LeBron thank you I just want to comment
a little bit on the Supreme Court
appointment um it goes back to the early
1900s and it has worked except for the
fact that there is no transparency as to
who is appointed and that goes for the
board too we don't know who's appointed
until until they pretty much come on
board um I we think there should be
transparency we think the court
does um a good job of vetting any
prospective applicants for the job they
um file applications they file letters
of recommendations they file written uh
work that they have done in Prior jobs
and
references and they do need to be
learned and experienced in questions of
Taxation or real estate
valuation or both and one must be ATT an
attorney and attorney wind is an
attorney um so our suggest question that
the court keep that phase of the of the
um nomination of of the
prospective um employee we think is very
important and then we would it would be
turned over to the governor and councel
and the governor and councel would then
review the
applications and hold hearings so that
there would be total transparency if
anyone had any issues with them and as
far as a removal of the uh any employee
who has is removed for malfeasance
misfeasance or anything in and for colum
one uh there is ambiguity there and
there has been issues in the past
where it the governor has to be involved
and the court has to be in involved and
it has caused timelines and uh problems
for the board members that is s still
sitting the two remaining board members
and we think that that should be in the
hands of the governor and Council and
not the
court and just one further thing on the
court if the court nominates any
further uh issues whether or not someone
seeks reappointments would go to the
governor and councel
also so we we think that's a good
alternative to the way the statute reads
and we do agree that the statute does
need transparency
and okay that's all I have thank you are
there any questions from the committee
representative leus then Gould and
manuti this might be for the chair or
somebody else um we have you know like
all the boards Pro PLC it's uh governor
and counsel but is that process normally
include a public hearing because this
explicit I know they're public meetings
but they have public hearings because
this is explicitly asking for a public
hearing as part of the governor and
councel SE um process and is that normal
or would that be it is it's certainly
not common on say public members to
licensing boards but uh for major things
that might be I I really don't know okay
thank you I think we're a quazi Judicial
agency um we we act very much like the
court does in hearing property tax
appeals eminent domain appeals so it's
important that they they these people be
vetted and it is important that there be
a public hearing so we are in agreement
of that follow up follow up yeah uh
again I don't know who this is too but
but but the concern is that they don't
normally have the process of having
public hearings that might be a change
that would be problematic there's
certainly public hearings for say
Commissioners okay so they know how to
do it all right thank you judges judges
yes exactly it's not not it may not be
for some of the boards we deal with but
they know how to do that representative
gold thank Madam chair is and and
forgive me if you said this but is there
a limit on how many terms um a member
can serve
no there isn't a limit on the number of
terms actually I've been a board member
since
1991 um I was a clerk prior to being the
board member so my experience is quite
extensive and we need that with the
board we need to have consistency in our
decisions so like the judges we we tend
to stay on longer than just a term
okay representative manui thank you
madam chair this is nothing to do with
the bill just curiosity we've been
talking about button and information
right hand side it says Governor Hugh
Gallen is the stationary old stationary
recycled no that is an old stationary
we're in the governor gallon Office Park
which is the on Pleasant Street there
nothing to do
no it was named after
him thank you that's a pretty clear
represent
goalie thank you madam chair just
curious
on why
the Supreme Court or the now the
governor and Council are picking the
chair versus the members amongst
themselves choosing a
chair um it it go back it goes back as
far as uh the early 1900s the the court
has always decided who would be the
chair um based on their experience and
once the chair leaves and they they
would appoint in all likelihood a chair
from the remaining board members and
then appoint a new board
followup would you be opposed if we
allowed the members to choose the chair
obviously you folks have been in the
position long enough to know who has the
experience I would hope you can make
that decision amongst yourselves
personing someone else making it for
you um I think it's a three- member
board and I think once the chair has
been appointed it's the chair does more
than what the board me other board
members do the chair does a lot of
administrative work works with the clerk
on a lot of issues the budget the rules
and the experience there is more
extensive than it is with a regular
member so once you have a chair I think
it's it's good to keep that chair on
until it's time to appoint another one
and the governor and Council I would
assume would be the ones that would
appoint the next chair when I retire
which may not be that long um
so uh I I think that that system
works all right thank you uh as a qu
quasi judicial board are you subject to
the age 70 retirement requirement the
judges have no we are not okay thank you
other
questions
Schmidt thank you madam chair um I I
have a couple questions um so I I serve
on the assessing Standards Board so uh
btla is a frequent subject of discussion
with regard to the issues that we
confront um but um uh the the question I
have well I want to point out one thing
and that is the governor does nominate
the Chief
Justice uh I don't think the Chief
Justice of the superior court is chosen
by the other judges I'm pretty sure the
Chief Justice of the district and the
and the superior court system are both
uh nominated and of course approved by
the uh by the GNC but nominated by the
governor so that's an answer so uh my
question
is uh since chairman Walsh is bringing
this bill um because there's an
inconsistency in the uh in the way the
the board is appointed Visa many of our
other boards uh are there any problems
uh that have plagued the btla in the U
in the recent past with any of the
current members complaints other than
people being unhappy with your decisions
obviously there's always a winner and a
loser you're talking about other board
members any complaints being filed I
am
I can tell you there has been but it's a
confidential matter that I cannot speak
about
okay thank you all right other
questions all right thank you very much
for your
stock
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee I will try to um keep my
comments brief and not repeat but um I
have been the board's clerk for going on
almost 23 years now and um I can what I
can add to this I fully support the
amendment and I have always believed um
and Michelle can attest to that that uh
since the day I got there I never
understood why there was um it was
written the way it was both on the um
hiring and the removal process process
it seemed to be it just fell short of um
processes that should be there and but
what I can tell you um I fully support
the fiveyear term um and I also have
listened to taxpayers for 23 years talk
about and ask questions about well how
are they appointed what's their
background what was the process and I've
tried to explain each person that I've
worked with and I've worked for many
different boards um Michelle's probably
been the constant um the constant but
I've worked with a lot of board members
and they all did bring something
different to the table but the five
years what I've also seen from my seat
um is the fact that
they if a new member comes on they
almost need a year or two just to get
caught up to speed yes they bring skills
to the table but as an adjudicative body
there's still a lot to learn and a lot
of people um if you're coming in say
from the appraisal world all of a sudden
you're thrown into what looks very much
like a courtroom um my own title as
clerk was modeled after a court clerk um
certainly don't get the salary let me be
clear but um but we're set up exactly
like a court when you come to us and and
we are user friendly for for the Joe
homeowner can do this himself and
represent himself in what is actually
looks and drives like a court but I
believe what I would focus you on when
you make any decisions um I I I love the
idea of the nomination and the the court
vetting the candidates um because yeah
you can re read a resume but when they
go in for an interview the statute in 71
B1 which you don't have specifically
says that they the board members must be
learned and
experienced in questions of
Taxation or real estate valuation and
Appraisal or both so we are all about
valuation and my concern um and I'm not
saying GNC can't do that but I want to
make sure that the right people come up
and put into these positions um and they
have those skills and I think the court
understands um because they see our
decisions um some of what we do is
appealable in different areas but I
really believe that that they are the
best folks to vet the candidates and
make sure that they fit that statutory
requirement and I do believe the five
years once you get somebody up to speed
to say a year and a half two years in 3
years they might be out the door who
knows but at least if they're there for
5 years we always had prior to 2011 we
always had a five-year term and I will
not even try to explain what had
happened but it wasn't at our request to
take it down to three the housing board
when when they came along three years
ago LBA called me and said hey do you
mind if we take your statute and model
it because we want to do this for the
house housing born I'm like well you can
copy and paste that's up to you but they
ended up with 5 years and I think that's
a good thing and I'm also chair of the
hooks at zoning board I know
representative Walsh he was at one point
when I was chair of the um I'm still
chair of the zba and he was chair of the
planning board so we've cross passed
there and um he and I both he a year ago
today actually Valentine's Day he and I
had a case at the I had a case at the
housing board it was my first experience
they are actually in the same building
as we are we went to a hearing and long
story short um I don't want to speak to
them but I see them very much in the
same light as somebody you know even a
zoning board is a is a quasi judicial
board we are sort of the judge and jury
of the facts to the to the law um so but
I I just want to point out the skill
level and they if you read what is
required for that board um they need a
land surveyor you know so maybe that is
GNC but for for what we do this this has
to be somebody that can you know really
understand what we we're trying to do um
because I guess you know we we see all
kinds of people but the skill level that
these members and members in the past
have brought to the board um makes the
product the court knows that the product
that we put out is of the highest
quality they take great pride and they
work tirelessly
um to follow the law and historically I
can understand back in the 1900s when um
there was a Board of Equalization and it
morphed into what we are today but we go
back that long way back to you know 115
years ago I understand why they were
trying to keep maybe the political
influence out of it they didn't have a
tax system in place they had nothing
over these last hundred years we have a
much better system in place much more
checks and balances much more oversight
and it makes sense that as history
evolves I think it's time that we evolve
and these processes just I guess it's
you know I'm not one if it's not broken
don't fix it but it's broken and I would
just ask you to fix it so thank you
thank you are there any questions goalie
and then
laus thank you madam
chair
so are you in favor of keeping these
courts making the nominations versus the
execu Council I'm a little confused is
that where you stand I agree with the
amendment that they that the board has
crafted to have the court do um the
nomination and part of that you know
interviewing process and then turn it
over to GNC because taxpayers and I am a
taxpayer I believe in transparency I
think the GNC the way I watch other
justices be you know put in those
situations of a public hearing I think
that's a fair process taxpayers can um
you know certainly voice their concerns
or or or not maybe in support and you
know I'll tell you a story of the 1990s
and I I wasn't there this was late 90s I
heard about it after I started there was
a situation where the court had
appointed a person um as a board member
and as it was told to me um they worked
for the agency for six months and
somehow once do got wind of it there was
a huge conflict with that person in the
state of New Hampshire and that person
had to resign and so if dot had been
provided a a
a public forum to voice that concern had
they known um maybe they could have
avoided all the time in expense of that
um so it's unfortunate but that's that's
a a situation followup and one more
followup I'm going to ask you same
question asked
before do you think whether it be
through the nominating processes Supreme
Court executive counsel or do you think
the board themselves should elect a
chair because I think they talk about
experience and everything else but those
members on the board as the three
members they are I think understand who
has the experience going forward to make
that decision themselves versus if the
chair should leave now also make an
appointment and appoint a new chair of
the board can't
they figure that out amongst
themselves
um I of course I think they I think they
could but I I always believe um and I
know I've heard this from different
court clerks over the years um they do
it by seniority and I think with
seniority you have that experience you
have that difference to um you know
because again some people will come in
and yes they they bring the skills
required by law but they just they don't
they're they're new to running a hearing
and that that is an art right um You
guys understand that and I think so I I
would just say I think GNC can can
definitely do that um I don't know I I
guess I don't have an opinion because I
I also believe they could do it so but
um again I like to think people can work
it out um but I also believe seniority
is the Golden Rule in some situations I
think I don't know it's messy and that's
why I I would hope instead of having to
go through another process with the
council and Governor that instead of
having we could skip that process and
let them do it themselves thank you yeah
black thank you um so my question is
just on the 3 versus 5year term uh
apparently there you've got people who
been on there for a long time so if you
could answer briefly what specific
problem has the three-year term
caused um since it seems like you have
people that have had pretty long tenure
and wouldn't that if there was a problem
with somebody obviate the need for doing
the removal process because they're
reappointment every three years but I
can only say I wish the court was here
to answer that for you honestly because
for
them um you know they've got to read
advertise as soon as you get someone in
and you you go through the whole process
it seems like it's time to go again um
and
again Eric wind is our newest member and
again um you know
he's he's going to be taking a coup you
know some time to get sort of get his
sea legs and then you know we're going
to have to go back to GNC again um I I
just don't see it worked what I know was
five years worked fine it worked fine
and I don't know again there's you know
thank you budgets are the way they are
it's sort of like getting reelected
years all right any uh any other
questions thank you very much for your
Frost
thank you madam chair and good afternoon
committee members I'm Ben Frost I'm the
deputy executive director of New
Hampshire housing I had not uh
anticipated testifying on this bill um
and I didn't indicate what my position
was on the pink card uh but when I heard
the testimony of the folks from the btla
I thought well that sounds like a
reasonable compromise uh I was the
original uh pre-introduction drafter of
the legislation that formed the housing
appeals board I worked closely with then
Senator Bob GAA uh to craft that
legislation based really largely on the
structure of the btla and we looked
closely at the btla statute then uh to
make decisions about how we thought the
housing appeals board should be formed
and we thought well this this seems
reasonable we liked the fact that the um
the members of the btla were appointed
by the Supreme Court uh because it
removes it from a political process and
we wanted to have that echoed by the
housing appeals board I understand
however the motivation behind the
legislation that and that is this was
expressed by um by uh representative
Lynn uh so after he retired as chief
justice became obviously a State Rep and
and he speaking on earlier housing
appeals board legislation he said as a
sitting Justice he didn't like the idea
that that he was appointing people whose
decisions he would be hearing on appeal
and I understood that too I think what
the the btla has proposed is a
reasonable marriage of the two uh it
removes it from the political process
but then also opens it to transparency
so my my hope is that if you uh wish to
move forward with that amendment that it
would also structurally apply to uh the
housing appeals board and do the same
thing for both because they the the
housing appeals board legislation was
really based on the structural the the
btla um to representative goalie's
question to two prior Witnesses um one
thing I'll point out is that um there
statutes vary I'll looking at New
Hampshire housing statute RSA 204c we
have a nine member board that is uh
appointed by governor and counsel the
chair of our board is appointed by the
governor
alone on an annual basis even though our
members have served fiveyear terms and
that works really well for us uh one
thing that that does is it removes the
possibility of internal popularity
contests which can create friction among
the members of a of a sitting board so
uh it works well for us what you choose
to do here well that's up to you I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
question no I think the other Witnesses
got their got your share as
well is there anyone else who wishes to
1456 all right seeing now I will close
the hearing and open the hearing on
House Bill
cler
thank you
you okay uh for the record I'm state
representative John cluder from Sullivan
County district 6 comprising the
communities of cyen and Claremont and
I'm here today in strong support of
House Bill
1545 which would amend current state law
so as to allow the governor and Council
to sell or lease Surplus state property
at less than fair market value if the
property is sold or leased to a
nonprofit entity for the construction
and development of affordable housing
House Bill 1550 1545 I believe is
another tool in New Hampshire's toolbox
to deal with the state's ongoing
affordable housing crisis a crisis that
affects nearly every community in our
state including my home community of
Claremont and a crisis that is now
causing much anxiety and suffering for
especially our most vulnerable citizens
who cannot afford the higher rents that
have risen over the past few years on
affordability that has resulted in
increased demands for housing assistance
and homelessness in many of our
communities including including again
Claremont a crisis which is discouraging
younger individuals younger families and
even businesses from relocating to the
Granite State a crisis which has develop
exacerbated the state's present labor
shortage and threatens our economic
future frankly I believe there are many
ways to deal with this crisis
but as many of you are beginning to
understand by now the best way to
alleviate and eventually solve the
crisis is to Simply construct more new
housing units or renovate for example uh
the New Hampshire bulletin and its April
27 2023 Edition cited the New Hampshire
Housing Authority as indicating the
state will need to construct at least
90,000 new housing units by 2040 to meet
current demand for affordable housing uh
this translates into approximately
5,295 units per year from
2023 through 2040 according to my
math In fairness I am noticing that
small steps are now being taken in our
state to deal with the crisis in
Claremont I noticed more landlords are
beginning to renovate substandard
apartment buildings in order to create
more
Apartments as for our state government
the invest New Hampshire State housing a
program launched in 2022 by the governor
is beginning uh the construction of new
housing units all over the state and
it's beginning to pay off the extra
money included in last year's final
version of the bipartisan operating
budget is also
helpful but I believe state government
can do more I really think they can do
more and House Bill 1545 is yet another
way to build more affordable housing
units House Bill 1545 is written would
allow sizable areas of State Surplus
property because I'm going to be frank
with you from my experience uh on the
long range Capital planning utilization
committee a lot of the property is is
not very large but there are I'm sure a
l some large tracks out there whether
open land or empty buildings in the
right
circumstances uh to be used for
affordable housing if a nonprofit
organization was willing to construct
such housing and the local communities
in which the Surplus property was loc
were located were supportive because I
know that's very important the
community's got to be supportive in
exchange the state with the ultimate
approval of the governor and
councel uh could sell or lease the
Surplus properties to the nonprofits at
less than fair market
value and I want to emphasize that house
bill 1545 would not directly cost our
state any money not a dime but the state
would simply could would simply get a
reduced price in Surplus property sales
if the if such properties are sold to
appropriate nonprofit individuals at
less than fair market value I want to
emphasize that there is no as I see it
no direct State cost also I want to
emphasize that this bill does not
preclude the state from selling State
Property Surplus property for housing to
private entities at full market value
that is still a possibility in other
words because the word May is in the
Bill's text it is only enabling or
legislation according to my uh
understanding in conclusion I'd be more
than happy to work with this committee
on any helpful amendments because I know
there's some con I've heard some some
concerns from some people already to
House Bill
1545 but I request that you all
eventually give this bill a positive
recommendation in some form so that our
state has another tool in its toolbox to
combat its affordable housing crisis
thank you very much for your time and
listening and I will do my best to
answer questions thank you
representative leus thank you um I'd
like you to explain your your statement
that this isn't going to cost anything
giving that money's fungible I don't
can't see how there's any difference
between foregoing re you know money
coming in and spending extra money I I
don't see any difference what difference
is there okay well in In fairness and
I'm On One Step I we talk the ultimately
is the government councel but I'm on the
long range Capital planning utilization
committee I've been in there for some
time and we're before it goes to
governor and counsel the state agencies
who are selling Surplus Pro have to come
to us and we have to decide whether it's
their requests are reasonable to sell it
at full market value and believe
me property we deal with with property
values all the time and property values
go up and property values go down so
well there may be no I mean it's not a
direct cost in the sense of an
appropriation you know but it's property
that goes up according to the for the
for the free market and this is
something so this bill would simply in
the right circumstances we could give a
a nonprofit or a break in the in the
sale so I guess it does cost some money
but to put a a fiscal note on it I just
can't say because this is an basically
enabling legislation and I feel it's the
right circumstances a piece of open land
or a piece a state empty State Building
might be available for if a a a
nonprofit came along to make create it
into Surplus housing all right thank you
so I don't hopefully that helps answer
your
question represent
Dolan thank you madam chair in the uh
thank you representative for taking my
question um in the um definition of of
stle property I am I correct to assume
this is real property and not trucks and
cars and things right it is nothing to
do with it is either open land or
buildings basically thank you thank
represent Simon thank you madam chair
thank you for your testimony oh you're
welcome um you made reference in your
testimony to the fact that loc
municipalities would have a say over
whether or not they wanted the
development to take
place um I'm just looking at the bill
itself and the reference statutes I'm
not seeing that anywhere is there some
place that you were pointing to to say
that that was the case or would we have
to okay and and I I just want of course
I don't know communities are different I
think some of them have Planning and
Zoning maybe some of them don't and and
depending on where the the Surplus
property was located in which community
that their local Planning and Zoning
statute might govern if if they have
them so maybe I I have to be a little
bit more careful but I'm just trying to
cover every situation and
not uh try to mislead this committee
saying it's it's it's an automatic thing
that if there's Surplus property
available in a nonprofit wanted to do it
they could get it they'd probably have
to work with the local community because
without the local community support I
have a feeling that wouldn't go through
in the
end thank you okay thank you represent
man py thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
does this also address that a lot of Old
Mill buildings and D capitated buildings
that could be partly owned by state
partly owned by local municipalities or
local
communities in that case how would that
work well and it it mainly is Surplus
State Property that's my intent now
there might be situations I don't know
whether where it's maybe owned by a
municipality and actually that brings me
up I know I was talking with my
colleagues about this legislation and
she thought it was a good idea and she
thought well why don't our munic
political subdivisions also do the same
thing because I'm sure some of them have
some Surplus state property and that's
that's not my intent with this bill but
if this inspires some of our political
subdivisions municipalities counties
school districts Etc more power to them
because I think we've got to use all the
tools that we can to solve this crisis
and government along with the PRI the
private sector obviously is probably
going to take the load but if Government
can work with the private sector to to
create help build more housing I think
in theot that's the way we're going to
get out of this in my opinion ultimately
we can deal with some of the side
effects but we've got to build more
housing in order to solve this crisis
that's my opinion thank you
representative CER thank you um
representative cluder you may have
covered this before and I apologize if I
missed what you
said could you just quickly go over what
the
standard selling a state Sur plus
property is and how would this be
different does this change the process
at all it it it um it would not I mean
my intent and I have the law it just
basically would add a a as a section and
if you read the text of the bill it
would add add a text that the
the ultimately the governor and Council
and there's a process would would be
able to sell it
without uh uh at less than fair market
value and I think it's it's RSA
440 and it would
amend uh yes I see what you're saying
par it would add another one under Roman
numeral 3 it would Roman numeral B where
right now you they we
basically ultimately the governor and
counsel but it's also the long range
committee has to if there's any surplus
State Property normally they're supposed
to sell it at fair at fair market value
or you know and that's what we've tried
to
do uh you know but of course Market real
estate values go up and go down and
obviously the intent of our committee
especially if we're selling to a private
entity is get the full fair market value
to reimburse see this covers all Sur
whether it's highway highway Surplus
property or general to get full fair
market to reimburse some of the state
costs and in the case of Highway you've
also got sometimes you have to reimburse
the federal government if it's a project
that the federal money has been used uh
that's the intent and I just want to
give a nonprofit who are willing to
create it's it's an incentive they would
get a break on the sale an exchange they
they build affordable housing whether
it's open land or empty state buildings
that that's the intent of this Bill
thank you hopefully that help okay thank
you other
questions represent Goldie
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question you're welcome
um I look at and you discussed it
earlier as to cities and towns zoning
determine whether or not housing is
available for those
positions what
happens if a nonprofit purchase a
purchases this piece of
property
and all of a sudden it's deemed that
it's unable to build these housing units
what happens then other words I I'm
going to assume and that the non does
due diligence and confers with the with
the municipality where the Surplus
property or is located first in order to
make sure they're on board uh before
going through with the purchase I would
think any nonprofit if they wanted to do
this project they would seek the input
of of the municipality in order for this
go through because if the municipality
objected there could be a real problem
uh they could deny and I don't Z
planning and zoning laws I mean the sale
could go through but hey if they can't
get the necessary permits there's a
there's a probably the the Ser uh
affordable housing wouldn't be
erected I and that could very easily
happen if the developer talks to
the um
Town manager for example and then some a
group of agreed citizens put a warrant
article through changing the zoning of
of a
parcel which has been known to happen
right and I I mean I would think
everything the nonprofit working would
have to line every get the community on
board first before per uh you know
purchasing this otherwise I don't think
they would go through that without
Community Support that would be sort of
my Common Sense on understanding but yes
bill what represent black us yeah I I
think if you look at the last and let me
know if if if you look at the last
sentence it says it'll be conveyed with
necessary covenants and restrictions so
it'll use for that purpose but what what
isn't clear is if they are unable to use
it for that purpose then what happens
and I think that needs to be clear so
other words if the nonp purchased it and
there were some restrictions or and then
they weren't allowed to build well and
then then this then probably they
couldn't wouldn't be allowed to build uh
but I'd be willing you know as I said
this is as I understand the language but
as I said I'm open to a to any helpful
amendments if that would help clarify
the intent of this Bill thank you
represent Brown thank you madam chair um
is there any uh priority thought of a
priority list if there's a nonprofit and
a private entity that want the same
property we'll read that again if I
guess if an if a if a private entity
wanted to create affordable housing
they'd go through the same process and
they if they were willing to pay full
market value I guess it would be the
Judgment of the long range committee and
the end the government Judgment of the
governor and counsel and because this
this is not mandate any it's it's uh or
as I see it it is uh enabling
legislation only uh and it does not stop
uh the state from selling to a uh a a
prep business if they whether it's
affordable housing or anything else as I
understand the bill that I've
drafted thank you other questions thank
you very much representative okay thank
you very much Ma Madam chair members of
Frost
oops
it's a
common thank you madam chair and good
afternoon again committee members I'm
Ben Frost I'm the deputy executive
director for New Hampshire housing um
speaking in support of this legislation
I want to thank representative cier for
introducing it I indicated uh support
with Amendment and um he he averred to
uh a alluded to a a you know possible
Amendment and I I have worked to draft
something and would be happy happy to
share that with the committee
um one of the concern well let me let me
back up the um New Hampshire housing as
a state entity uh not an agency but an
instrumentality of state government has
the statutory ability to acquire uh
Surplus State Property uh essentially to
assert a preemptive right to do so uh
and that is pursuant to existing statute
um and we can do that um and we have
done this a few times and we're
currently engaged with the Department of
Transportation on a couple of parcels of
land uh that we will then put out to
development for affordable housing not
necessarily for nonprofit uh developers
but any for-profit or nonprofit would be
eligible to um compete for the
opportunity to develop those properties
this bill um gives would give us
essentially a leg up because right now
we're paying fair market value for this
the Surplus properties coming from dot
uh this would provide the opportunity
for us to acquire properties um
potentially from the the the state at
less than fair market value which
savings we could then pass on to a
developer who could then make a
development more affordable whether they
are for-profit or nonprofit this however
is limited to uh
nonprofits um I'll point out a couple of
things that would be of concern to me uh
as written uh this legislation if
adopted uh would put the state
effectively into the position of being a
project
underwriter and also the long-term asset
manager of the properties ensuring that
once built uh that it continues to be
used for the purposes for which uh it
was intended as when sold by the state
and I I'm not sure that is a position
the state wants to be in I would say
however that that is the position that
New Hampshire housing does already serve
um and so the an amendment that I would
suggest would refer to existing statute
RSA
204d which is the Surplus land statute
for the state which puts New Hampshire
housing in the position of acquiring
property from the state here if it were
done under the condition that it be
transferred to a nonprofit organization
to build affordable housing then uh the
state agency would be and and frankly
long range would also be enabled to uh
dispose of the property at less than
fair market value those are savings
again that we could pass on to uh a
developer say that number again that is
RSA
204d 204 or hyphen D um so I have uh
drafted a drafty Amendment uh that would
achieve that purpose there may be
something else that needs to be done
with that um but thank you if you pass
it out we will consider it I will be
happy to pass it around happy to take
any questions too okay so if if I
understand you correctly you're saying
that New Hampshire housing already has
the authority to obtain Surplus
land resell it to at whatever you can
get to a developer for affordable
housing or any other purpose of other
housing purposes we only do affordable
housing there are some situations where
we there might be mixed income housing
but the focus is always affordable
housing with that definition as noted in
the legislation in RSA
204c
561 okay and your statute and rules of
deal with what happens if the zoning
changes or or
whatever well it it to the extent I was
able to to follow the question before um
it we would really be interested in
acquiring property uh where there is
development potential and that's what
we're doing right now in our
negotiations with the Department of
Transportation uh so we're working with
the department and we're working with
the municipality uh where the property
is situated uh so we look for uh
situations where the existing zoning
permits what we're trying to do uh we we
have no real interest in in bucking the
municipal regulatory process um we don't
have the the ability to frankly um if if
a um development were TR or if property
were transferred to us and then the
zoning changed well then we'd have to
probably sell it to someone who could
use the property for the properly zoned
purpose thank you represent Simon thank
you madam chair um in your testimony you
said that you felt like one of the
benefits of this was you that you would
be able to um acquire the property at a
lower rate and therefore pass it on to a
developer at a lower rate which would
allow them to create more affordable
housing which I'm assuming is the really
the entire purpose of the bill but is
there any guarantee that by passing the
property on at a lower rate it will in
fact turn into cheaper housing what
would keep the developer from keeping
the rates at the higher level but just
acquiring the property at a lower
level that's a great question
representative um and it really comes
back leans back on our processes at New
Hampshire housing that's our purpose for
existing is to develop affordable
housing and we're not interested in
working with developers who uh frankly
aren't going to do that and we impose
long-term guarantees that are legally
enforcable uh that include the ability
to foreclose on the properties if
they're uh not meeting the the required
conditions and Covenants great thank you
represent man py thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question um when
you acquir the Housing Authority does do
the due diligence in terms of uh wetland
land conservation land all those things
what is the develop developable
developable parcel of land
correct follow question yeah so when you
say affordable housing what are the
different categories lowincome Workforce
missing
mle or what other categories Does it
include uh thank you for the question
representative if you refer to the the
the statutes cited in the bill uh that
takes you essentially to a definition or
a series of definitions that include um
low income housing which is housing uh
or moderate income housing which is
housing that is Affordable to people
making up to 80% of median income low
income housing which is uh 60% of median
income very low-income housing which is
50% of median income those are all
included in our statute and that's
that's embodied in this
Bill okay representative Simon thank you
just a quick follow-up question to my
previous one um you said that you do
have guarantees that they'll do what
they or you can foreclose um are those
guarantees in perpetuity or is there a
limitation on them or how does that work
uh it thank you for the question the we
um there are some legal barriers to
doing perpetuity um one of which is well
not so much a legal barrier but a
practical barrier and that is
perpetuities are very long time and you
don't know what the future may bring we
do impose long-term restrictions um and
it depending upon the the source of
funding of something U then it might
be absolute minimum of 20 years of
affordability and that's in the
affordable housing fund statute uh the
federal funding that we utilize and is
utilized by developers that we work with
tends to require 30 uh minimum 30 years
of affordability but we often push that
up up to 40 or 60 years of affordability
and we are in the process right now of
changing one of our rules that would
allow us to move up to 75 years of
affordability which is a pretty long
time thank you yes by then you'll have
to rebuild the
housing at probably sooner than 75 years
they they tend to require
recapitalization 20 or 30 years out
ah thank you that's good to know and
representative gold thank you madam
chair thank you Ben for taking my
question you had mentioned that right
now currently the Housing Authority has
the option to buy at market value
Surplus property correct correct and is
that limited to you and no other
nonprofit the statutes allow for both a
a municipality in which the property is
situated and New Hampshire housing
effectively we have competing preemptive
rights um and we generally you know if
the municipality wants to acquire it we
step back and let them do that
um but right now and I'm I don't want to
say the T what the town is because there
are some negotiations going on but uh in
this place where we're acquiring
properties from the Department of
Transportation the town is taken a pass
and they're supportive of what we're
trying to do which is very helpful uh
so we have that um statutory tension
between the two that we we are living
with uh comfortably um depending upon
which depending upon how the state
acquired property uh what source of
funding was used does guide and
sometimes require how the state will
then dispose of it once it once it
becomes Surplus uh this bill helps uh
with some of those strictures follow
follow and so am I thank you for that
answer am I understanding correctly that
this bill would also open up the
opportunity to other nonprofits besides
New Hampshire housing to obtain the
property directly from the state yes and
and that's a really excellent question
because right now this says to be quite
to be transferred to a
nonprofit We are not a nonprofit
organization we're an instrumental it of
state government so this essentially
takes us out of the picture and is in
conflict with RSA 204d which gives us a
preemptive right so this as introduced
there is a statutory conflict I have an
amendment that would help to resolve
that but the conflict is only if you if
you're talking about the less than fair
market
value okay thank you I thought any other
questions
thank you for your testimony we will
appreciate your Amendment and I will
pass it out right now thank you thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
1545 okay not seeing
anybody close the public hearing and
recognize representative groa for an
1095 represent
okay
anything thank you madam chair I'm
Jackie groa representative for District
24 the towns of Ryan
Greenland this amendment has a little
bit of a history in that it um reflects
the changes that were made last year
with House Bill 6 35 540 some of the
changes in House Bill 2 that we accepted
and it looks like a
lot and originally was going to be an
amendment that we were going to look at
um last year but we didn't have time for
that and then the Senate was going to
take it up as a bill but OS had a hard
time trying to jiggle into their
schedule so we took it back as an
amendment and you'll look at through
most most of it you'll see that board is
replaced by the
office and there's the addition of RSA
310 which is the RSA that defines the
responsibility of of the um
oplc there are other things in here but
the most of it it really has to do with
all the changes that we made and I might
suggest that rather than we addressing
it here we we could go at we can go at
it in a subcommittee and willing to sit
through some of the concerns and some of
the questions that people may have does
that make sense makes sense to me and if
you you could give it to me to
save dear representative luckus from yet
another bill in a
subcommittee thank you he may have made
a comment earlier about
that okay very good any any questions uh
yes representative goalie
thank you Mr chair and
yeah I understand the process of where
we're
at but I just first of all very
disappointed to get 112 page Amendment
it seems like this is getting to be a
norm here versus the proper procedure of
coming in as legislation or dividing it
up into separate sections um so that we
have smaller pieces to handle going
forward I'm glad to hear you're willing
to take it on but it's while it changes
board and oplc and a lot there's awful
lot of repeals in here that I'm seeing
as well that I think should be going
through line by line and I'm not sure we
really have the time to go through 112
pages of looking all the repeals and
actually pulling them up um as we go
forward but I'm hoping you're
willing with the subcommittee and the
work of this committee to do the due
diligence before going forward with this
and if we have to inm study it and come
back next year
because this is crazy to put it bluntly
I agree about this being here now this
late in the
hour take I understand I will take that
responsibility any other
questions thank you very much thank you
and also a lot of pink card appreciate
Susi
afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Karen Susi I work
at she andin Capital group and I'm here
on behalf of the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association we are
the uh representatives of the
manufactured homes Park owners
installers Etc everything in the
industry um just focusing in particular
on page 92 of the amendment Line 6
through
8 it appears that uh the board of
manufactured housing is attempting to be
nine inert the reason behind repealing
that board was that it had not had any
cases I believe for five or six years
within its jurisdiction and that's why
it was proposed to be
repealed okay thank you for bringing it
to our attention we'll we'll take a look
Thompson perfect
timing
always wanted to say this good morning
chairman
Simon are you
in oh did I say good morning I'm sorry
good afternoon uh Simon Thompson I'm
with Sheen finny Capital group here on
behalf of the electrical contractors
Business Association as representative
goalie mentioned this is a very lengthy
Bill I'm just going to draw your
attention to page 77
proposes line number uh starting on line
eight where it crosses out the board
shall maintain and make available a list
of such persons approved for level one
and level two thirdparty electrical
inspections we would request that that
language remain in the bill uh third
party inspectors are
important uh to to the overall housing
kind of industry in that a lot of rural
towns do not have uh their own
inspectors and so when a general
contractor or an electrician needs to
get their work inspected they need to
have a place of reference to go to to um
call and find these uh qualified uh
approved thirdparty
inspectors um so we would wish that that
would stay in the current RSA
further down um just one other point
starting on line 20 that deletion uh
again we would prefer that that stay in
the bill uh we would make one change if
it's helpful proof of completion shall
be furnished to the board by the lensey
period This is for when you do your
continuing education um
work uh that the board keeps a list of
folks who've done their continuing
education so that we can at all times
know uh when an electrician is in good
standing and furthermore the rest of
that deletion failure to complete the
continuing education shall render the
electric electrician license that whole
deletion we'd like to keep all of that
in the RSA so those are the two uh
issues that we wanted to bring to the
committee's attention happy to
participate any the subcommittee work on
this but again you know this is just one
page of 12-page bill and we found kind
of two issues that um really would like
to I don't think really had anything to
do with any of the past legislation that
passed um so we just wanted to make sure
those do remain happy to answer
questions great thank you for your
questions seeing on thank you very much
thank
Stevens
that on yes okay hi I'm Sher Stevens I
am a New Hamshire certified midwife and
I'm here representing myself today um on
the amendment of HB
1095 the concern I have is on page 35
lines 20 through
29 the um practical experience um
requirements being prescribed by the um
office versus the council it's including
specific things like prenatal visits
postpartum follow-ups and things like
that and then
um I'm sorry yep it's page 35 um lines
20 to
29 yeah and then on 25 they're talking
about the technical skills being
prescribed by the office and on 28 it's
talking about um an examination being
approved 26 and 28 are talking about
examinations and this is kind of the
core
um skills um qualifications and things
like that that a midwife would would
need to have to be certified and I
understand that this bill is a lot about
um oplc taking over the administrative
duties and the um discipline duties and
things like that which we understand is
a done deal and that is um understood
and and okay with us but these seem to
overstep that and sort of come down to
the core values of what we do as our in
our training and I'm just concerned that
um if the office of Professional
Licensing has um being able to prescribe
how many prenatal visits we have to do
before we get certified I don't think
they have the expertise and the
understanding for that process and um
you know I'd be happy to work with them
and and help them understand that but at
this point I'm concerned that they could
come up with any number of anything that
they wanted and it essentially put us
out of business if they chose to I don't
think that's their intention but it does
make us
vulnerable um and then
on page 34 on line um 13 it does give us
the council um the mid refe Council um
being the ability to adopt the rules for
qualifications and so I feel like we
we're adopting the rules for
qualifications and then on this line
they're having the oplc tell us what our
qualifications are are and that seems
me any questions thank you for your
testimony any questions from the
committee yes representative
gold my understanding that the conflict
you're talking about represents As I
understood it the board or yeah The
Advisory Board now right is board yet no
the council yes Council okay thank you
the council is a establishing or or
advising the um helping with the
establishment of the rules and the
parameters and so therefore it doesn't
conflict over here because the office is
simply going by the rules set with the
guidance of the council I would agree
with that if it didn't say that the U
technical skills are prescribed by the
office the um examination is approved by
the office up here on 9 20 the
requirements are prescribed by the
office so so would it be helpful oh
follow up thank you would it be helpful
then if um if where it said uh
requirements
as formed in consultation with the
council were Blah Blah Blah by the
office I mean I think the intent here
clearly is that it's a it's just a
clerical task that you all are not
leaving your jobs to go do what the
office staff can do they're following
out what was pre agreed on as I
understand it so how how does the
language get how would you like to see
or
request that that language I mean I
understand um if we're going to The
Advisory Board which I am opposed to but
if they are going to um at least if it's
being prescribed by the board by the
office that they would um right be in
consultation with the um mid refe board
at this point in Ru making we are making
the
qualifications so I feel like we're
making those qualifications and then um
this gives them the power
to it just it just seems like a conflict
to me they're they're making we're
making the rules and they're um
prescribing what we can and can't do one
last question um yeah just just a
reminder we're going to be hashing this
out in subcommittee so I don't want to
get too deep into it here okay
and my apologies you need to understand
I'm not uh prescribing what future
actions are going to happen we're
handling a whole lot of things and so I
didn't mean to insinuate anything about
the Midwife report about changes coming
up no no problem and I'm really happy
that this is going to sub commmittee and
we can deal with these little details in
more um a different
place any other question uh yes
representative mench py thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
question um currently the council sets
the parameters for education training um
recertification continuing at all of
those things and where do you see
that process being disrupted in this
amendment um by them changing the
prescribed um the requirements the
Practical experience experiences
requirement prescribed by the office
versus the
Council on those
lines so in that currently it's done by
the council and in this it indicates the
office right it would be one thing if
the if we make the prescriptions for
what our training is and the office of
Professional Licensing is just right
following that when they're doing the
um recertification or the certification
they're just following what we do this
kind of gives them the power to make
those those particular um requirements
and that's what I have a concern
with representative
Brown thank you Mr chair could
you go back and explain to me what you
said about this makes you vulnerable
because I I I was writing and didn't
catch everything and I want to make sure
I understood what you meant by that sure
um if the if this does give the office
of Professional Licensing the power to
prescribe how many uh practical
experiences we need by how many prenatal
visits we need before we get certified
and how many you know they could make
that astronomical number they could make
it a lesser number that we think is is
qualified and I just you know and and
there's different things like technical
skills they could prescribe to us that
we need to have technical skills that
are outside our you know ability to
obtain follow up um so it makes
individual midwives potentially
vulnerable is that what you mean the
profession as a whole I mean you you
want to have the um all these
qualifications want to go in line with
what our rules are and our scope of
practice
is goie thank you Mr
chair uh going to page
28 pass a a written examination now it's
council but when I look at page
34 the scope of practice and procedures
for the practice of mid wee including
policies and professional Direction and
supervision and the El and below that
eligibility requirements for the
certification fall in the role of the
council is that not contradicting given
the
yes that's the ability to pick the exam
versus the council well that is
something I would would disagree with
that they they would be able to pick the
exam so there's um on line 26 there's a
certification
examination which is
um I don't want to get into details with
you but it's the narm exam it's the
North American registry of midwives
which is what makes us be able to then
become cpms which which certifi
professional midwives which the
requirement of becoming an New Hampshire
certified midwife so that exam which is
not clarified in this because it's
clarified in our rules like this is the
law keeps it open and because NM if
something happened in arm the New
Hampshire would have to come up with
that with that examination themselves
and the um one that you're talking about
the written exam the oplc is making that
um they're taking that as far as I
understand from our meetings they're
going to take that and put it online
that's all based on the rules and the
the state law the state law and the
state rules so that a midwife coming in
they have to pass that exam at at this
point there's like 20 questions that
they go to the oplc and pass before they
get certified and they're going to put
that online and make make it more open
book so that the
um the uh applicants would then need to
know where the rules are and go through
and get that so that's that exam the one
before that is our national exam that
allows us to be certified in New
Hampshire follow but my question is it's
changed from the exam approved by the
council which I feel is appropriate to
an exam approved by now oplc don't you
think the council should have the
ability to choose the exam absolutely
that is my disagreement with this yeah
thank
you for clarification purposes on that I
believe it actually says that the
examination has been administered
by the council not just chosen by it in
the
past yeah well they're striking it out
now it wasn't stricken out before right
we I don't have any problem with oplc
administering the exam that's fine with
me I don't even have honestly a problem
with them doing the one um that is
pertaining to the laws and the rules
because that's very
concrete okay it's the one above that
that allows us to practice and that's a
much different exam yep uh any other
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your testimony appreciate it uh did
anybody else wish to speak on Amendment
Courtney good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee lindsy Courtney
executive director
oplc um I wish to thank representative
Gera for bringing this amendment forward
um and for all of you and taking the
time to to review the bill I know that
it's a a lengthy bill
um essentially what we have in the
office is we have a series of changes
statutorily transferring certain
Authority uh from the boards to the
office over the last several years and
unfortunately throughout that process we
have not statutorily removed that
conflicting Authority from the boards
and it has created a a huge challenge
operationally for the office and for the
boards particularly as it relates to rul
making this has been going on for years
and I think it's been compounded by the
changes from last session so I you know
I'm sensitive to the fact that this is a
large bill but um we really do need some
changes in our statutes um we are
starting to see rules are still being
moved forward by the boards for which
they shouldn't have and they don't have
statutory Authority but because of the
conflicts in the law they're moving
those rules forward oplc is taking op
you know taking objection to those rules
it's creating a mess operationally so we
have to make some changes there are some
things in this bill that I think we need
to work on um Midwifery certainly Miss
Stevens pointed some out at the time
this was drafted a lot of the language
was drafted I believe hb2 was still in
the works and so there were some changes
contemplated um that correspond with the
changes here because this was
essentially the back half of hb2 that
you saw last year so I think there are
certainly some things that we need to
address in subcommittee but as a whole
as a matter of policy we do need to
remove the conflicts and the conflicts
are really twofold conflicts respect to
who
licenses the uh individuals in
accordance with criteria established by
the boards now you made clear last
session that it should be the office but
all of the boards have retained that
Authority in their statutes and most of
the boards have gone along with the
transition but there are a handful that
are insisting on reviewing um
applications and I think we need some
clarity from the legislature as to who
is who should be doing that and that's
what this is intended to address same
thing regarding approval of education
programs in accordance with the criteria
established by the boards um there's a
little bit of disciplinary language in
here I think we addressed most of that
last session but there is a little bit
of that um and then who does the
renewals so it's definitely large and
the reason why it's large is because the
office's regulatory framework is
extremely vast it's very much like
Health and Human Services we have a lot
of statutes and unfortunately they were
not all drafted at the same time to be
consistent with each other and it we're
running into problems operationally and
so I would ask for your support happy to
work with members of the subcommittee to
get it right um go through it with a
fine tooth com but we really do need to
make some changes thank you for your
time I'd be happy to answer any
questions any questions for the
directory yes repres
goalie thank you Mr chair and thank you
question my big concern is and you heard
it is 112 Pages here in front of us that
goes well beyond just taking away the
authority of the boards giving it to you
instead on what's going on my question
is why wasn't that part brought forward
as one bill and then the rest of it
brought
in as something else
it's bothers me to be here today with
112 page Amendment with the concerns you
had from folks out there that are
legitimate
concerns whereas if you were truly
wanted to make those changes of taking
opcs charge over the boards could have
easily been done with all everything
without everything else that's in here
certainly uh thank you representative
goalie and to be clear this is this bill
came out of the hp2 session last year
this was not the mechanism that I would
have liked to have you review this bill
um and I know that the sponsors made
several attempts to um find a different
mechanism um essentially hb2 included
this language last year or the bulk of
the language and it was decided at that
point in time because there was not
enough time to review it that you would
essentially divorce that um the back
half from hb2 moved forward with the
front half the front half that's now
creating conflicts in the law is the
problem and so there was a commitment
from this committee I believe to review
that and to move forward with it um on a
retained bill which was 518 and so then
again uh I know representative grota uh
tried in October um after about a month
director alak cona said can't do it
can't move forward and I believe the
filing deadlines had passed so I reached
out to Senator Rosenwald and I said this
is going to be a problem for us she
agreed to file an LSR um or to amend her
an existing LSR and to put it on that um
and then at some point Senator Rosenwald
said that the speaker had a different
mechanism for solving the problem and uh
I think that mechanism was an amendment
to this bill so I don't think anybody
intended this amendment to play out the
way it did
my preference would have had to have
this legislative body pass it as a
package either with hb2 655 409 same
bill was heard multiple times last
session um but unfortunately that's
where we're at um and and and again I'm
sorry for any part that I played in that
but uh but but that's how it ended up
here
follow
I
get be careful how say be um you look at
it and you say well I wish it would have
gone through in House Bill 2 and hearing
the concerns and the complaints on the
language here today if this had gone
through in House Bill 2 where would we
be
today well on Midwifery specifically
House Bill 2 contemplated moving them to
advisory which is why you have this
language and so by divorcing it and not
and not making those changes in
hb2 um I think that is that is part part
of the challenge I I disagree with
respect to the electrical comments if
you look at actually what's proposed to
be repealed it's language that says that
the board shall um review information or
information shall be provided to the
board that's not the process that's
contemplated by the statutory changes so
I I think if if we were to spend time
which I know is what you would like
talking through some of the stakeholders
that the issues that they've identified
don't think are actual issues with
respect to manufactured housing um I I
don't read this bill as proposing to
bring back the complaint board what I re
read this bill to do is to include the
jurisdiction that was within the
complaint board under the installers
board because if you remember in House
Bill 2 that eliminated the complaint
board so I think part of the problem was
created by the fact that the what
happened last session which is to take
the back half of off of to and decide to
separately uh sure representative
greater than repres okay so I just want
to address the first of all I want the
committee to realize this is what
happens when we make big changes okay
because all the stuff is intertwined and
at the end somebody has to since we we
own it because we made all these changes
number two um you might recall that the
beginning of this of this particular
year we had a lot of oplc bills which
were similar to House Bill 2 so what
this and this is why we have to go
through this I'm sorry now that I think
about it with you um is because if you
don't you know for example and some of
the um bills that you have which make
which reinstates an Advisory board for
the Manufacturing Housing group and puts
the midwif as a an Advisory Board all
all these things if you if those things
somehow don't come out exactly the same
as what as the legis this is going to
get affected so that's
why um when we first and what represent
what direct Courtney said I keep
promoting her to representative um what
directing Courtney says is true I mean
this has been I didn't I'm the believe
me I'm the last person that wants to
bring a huge book to a committee but
this has been we've been we've tried
this we've been trying to work on this
since the last August this is how long
we've been sitting on this so um I
apologize but at the same time at this
point we just have to deal with it and
I'm willing to take it on I'm willing to
take it on sorry I just want to
everybody realize why we are where we
are thank you representative leas and I
was actually going to make some of the
comments that representative grota just
did um the subcommittee is working
through House Bill 1271 we're actually
meeting again tomorrow morning and we
haven't gotten to some of the parts like
manufactured housing uh Midwifery and
some others but um you know well I
didn't want to take on 122 page Bill
we're going to have to stay in touch and
so you know maybe if we do p we decide
to go forward with some of these maybe
they'll come out of this thing or
whatever we'll talk about it um but yeah
it's complicated thank
you any other question yes represent
and thank you um Mr chair and uh yes you
know having this com
comprehensive Encyclopedia of what needs
to be done uh is helpful because the all
the bills that we have in our
subcommittee you know we are changing
from office to executive director
executive director office the
consistency to know where the
consistencies what the changes are going
to be this is helpful to have
this and uh I appreciate that it's a lot
of work but we have to do it thank you
and just a reminder uh to the committee
we're we're not in an executive session
we're asking questions of the of the
people up front so we'll try to keep it
to that yes representative
schm thank you Mr
chairman uh so uh this is the kind of um
small detail stuff that that happens in
large
bills I I've been here now for 22 years
I have seen on occasion when the process
you know Skips a page you you name it
little details that get
overlooked uh get uh left out whatever
it is but it's something that is
imperfect and needs to be
fixed
and it happens and the alternative is we
basically say oh well leave it the way
it is and that's kind of like saying
that the Christmas tree lights don't
come on because we didn't connect these
two wires but just leave it that way and
if it flickers what the hell uh
something like this happened I think
with the
Challenger uh when something got
overlooked is there a question yeah
there is a question I'm dealing with the
the I'm not asking a question I'm making
a statement that we are we are we are
talking about the situation which is on
us to fix I I I agree and it's going
it's going to sub commmittee we can
discuss but right
now you've I'm not the point is that
we've gotten into the discussion so now
we have to get back out of the
discussion but a few things have to be
clarified and it this is a
representative gr said this is on us to
fix and it's going to get fixed in the
subcommittee and so some of these little
uh little
matters um are causing some confusion it
will be worked out in the subcommittee
but it is appropriate and as the old
saying goes we ain't making sausage here
and now we're making
sausage thank you any further
questions thank you very seeing none I I
do have one uh really quick it is an
actual question um and it maybe goes a
little bit outside the scope of just the
bill itself so uh it might be helpful
heading into subcommittee uh I'm sensing
anyway a lot of confusion um in the
distinction between the office setting
criteria and the office working in
conjunction with the board and using the
board's um you know to to make that
criteria if you could when you come to
the subcommittee although I don't want
to step on the chair of the
subcommittee's toes at all um just
clarify for us the relationship and how
that works and where to find it in stat
stat so that we can refer back to it so
that there isn't this constant confusion
in question about whether or not who's
actually setting the criteria and who
has the power to set the criteria that
would be very helpful certainly I can do
that um just for reference it's in RSA
chapter 310 which basically says the uh
the office has to um implement or
license people in accordance with the
criteria established by the
boards thank you thank you uh sorry
representative you know try and make
this a question so uh would you think
it'd be helpful for this
subcommittee uh if I or someone sent
them a link to the beginning of what we
did with House Bill 1271 and on that one
since it did a lot of moving to advisory
um we about spent about an hour hashing
out what's the difference between
advisory and a statutory
committee yes I think that would be
helpful I'll try and do that thank you
any other questions thank you for your
time thank you very much director
appreciate it would anyone else like to
1095 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing um that will be referred to
subcommittee which I will leave to the
chair to straighten out and uh we are in
time
it too mucho complicated we didn't have
yeah all right so it's refer to
representative gera's subcommittee and
when are we meeting again Mr
chair our next meeting together is next
Tuesday and the uh license seat
subcommittee is meeting tomorrow morning
am